Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim
Pridlaff und ihr hört die 114.
Ausgabe von UKW, eurem Krisen-Podcast, der sich heute, den 6.
Oktober 2023, wieder einmal um die Ukraine kümmert.
Das Problem ist noch nicht weg
und ich begrüße daher Pawel auf der anderen Seite des Kanals. Hallöchen.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, ich hab jetzt ganz bewusst mal das Datum auch fallen gelassen,
weil ich das ab und zu mal vergesse.
Einerseits. Andererseits, weil das auch nicht ganz unwichtig ist.
Nicht, weil das jetzt ein besonderes Datum ist, sondern eben,
weil wir jetzt wieder auf ungefähr einen Monat von Kriegsaktivität zurückblicken
und die letzten Sendungen waren,
glaube ich, in einem ähnlichen Abstand, ne das ist nicht ganz richtig.
Wir haben zuletzt auf zwei Monate zurückgeblickt und davor hatten wir mal ein
paar häufigere Updates.
Also wir haben jetzt sozusagen wieder einmal, übrigens genauso wie im letzten Jahr auch,
den Sommer nur so sporadisch begleitet, was jetzt keinerlei,
wie soll ich sagen, nicht davon kündet, dass wir jetzt weniger uns das Geschehen anschauen würden.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, weiterhin sehr intensiv getan.
Es ist halt nur so, dass die Gesamtsituation so ist, dass wir uns eigentlich
immer noch im selben Prozess finden und es wenig Not getan hat,
hier wöchentlich immer wieder dasselbe zu erzählen.
Aber so nach vier, fünf Wochen muss man dann doch schon mal wieder ein bisschen zusammenfassen.
Ich hätte fast gesagt, ja im Osten nichts Neues, aber ganz so ist es nicht.
Nein, nein, ganz so ist es nun wirklich nicht. Ja, fangen wir an,
wie immer, mit dem Überblick über die militärische Aktivität.
Das wird in gewisser Hinsicht auch den Schwerpunkt dieser Sendung, glaube ich, ausmachen.
Nochmal so zur Erinnerung, wir haben es also mit einem Frontverlauf zu tun,
der sich eben vom Nordosten der Ukraine nach Süden runter erstreckt,
bis ungefähr 100 Kilometer vor dem Asowschen Meer,
dort in Donbass macht die Front einen Knick und zieht nach Westen rüber Und
geht dann halt da an dem Sinnipro Staubecken,
wo jetzt kein, wo der Staudamm ja leider weg ist,
sozusagen die großen Wassermassen weg sind, der Fluss nur noch wie ein Rinnsal fließt,
was dort halt große Landbereiche freigesetzt hat, aber die sind eben alle noch
nicht nutzbar, weil das einfach matschiges, morastiges Gebiet ist.
Und natürlich geht der Frontverlauf noch weiter, dann eben am Fluss bis zur
Mündung des Schwarzen Meers.
Und ja, der ganze Bereich südlich davon ist halt nach wie vor russisch besetzt,
einschließlich der Krim.
Lass uns jetzt mal so zum allgemeinen Frontverlauf.
Und es gibt an diesem Frontverlauf halt Schwerpunkte der Aktivität.
Und im Wesentlichen ist es auch schon so, wie ich es in der letzten Sendung berichtet habe.
Das heißt es gibt in diesem Nordosten gibt es Bereiche,
wo die Russen Vorstöße wagen oder zumindest versuchen,
das kann man im Wesentlichen unter Ablenkungsmanöver abbuchen,
weil diese Bereiche sind nicht wirklich militärisch besonders stark ausgerüstet.
Hier geht es einfach nur darum, um die Ukraine auch möglichst an vielen Stellen
beschäftigt zu halten, weil natürlich, klar, selbst wenn man irgendwo um eine
Offensive bemüht ist, will man natürlich nicht an einer anderen Stelle gleich wieder Land verlieren.
Das ist halt so dieser Bereich in der Region Kharkiv oder Luhansk, also an der Grenze.
Und es gibt halt verschiedene Vorstöße auf die einst in dieser großen Rakiv-Offensive
genommene Stadt Kupyansk, also nicht direkt auf die Stadt, sondern halt im Vorfeld,
aber da passiert nicht sehr viel.
In den letzten fünf Wochen ist es glaube ich den Russen nur gelungen ein einziges Dorf einzunehmen,
wobei man, wenn man von diesen Dörfern an der Frontlinie von Dorf redet,
dann ist es halt eher so eine benannte Stelle auf der Karte,
wo mal ein Dorf war, weil das ist halt mittlerweile alles natürlich kurz und
klein gebombt, von daher ist da auch nicht viel zu holen und das sind halt einfach
nur so hin und her Manöver.
Auch da, wo die Rakiv-Offensive zuletzt geendet ist, um Kriminal herum gibt
es immer mal noch wieder so Aktivitäten.
Aber das sind alles so Gebiete, die sind einfach nicht besonders gut ausgestattet.
Durch geografische Bedingungen und weil sich die Russen dort eben jetzt über
eine längere Zeit haben eingraben können, geht es da an der Front nicht wirklich weiter.
Auch nicht für die Ukraine, weil auch die Ukraine das nicht so priorisiert.
Also der ganze Vorstoß nach Osten, auch wenn sie natürlich immer klar sagen,
dass es ihr Ziel ist, alle Gebiete zu befreien, aber zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist
es eben sehr viel wichtiger, Vorstöße im Süden zu machen und deswegen ist halt
hier an der Nordostfront relativ wenig los.
Das ändert sich dann ein bisschen, wenn man noch etwas weiter südlich dann auf
dieser Frontlinie herunterrutscht um Bachmut.
Das ist ja die Stadt, die von den Russen mit einem unfassbaren Verlustaufwand
eingenommen wurde im letzten Jahr und wo es dann aber auch für die Russen dann nicht weiter ging.
Seitdem drückt die Ukraine nördlich und vor allem südlich dieser Stadt wieder
die Russen zurück und beschäftigt die Russen dort.
Es ist ein bisschen unklar, warum die Ukraine dort so viel Wert drauf legt,
aber es ist halt, glaube ich, auch in diesem Kontext zu sehen,
Die Ukraine versucht die Russen da zu beschäftigen.
Wo es ihnen opportun erscheint und führt ja auch generell so einen Abnutzungskrieg,
dazu werden wir auch nochmal viel sagen.
Und der Aufwand, den die Russen aufwenden müssen, um dann diese Stellung zu
halten, ist halt sehr groß.
Und das sieht man gerade an dieser südlichen Bachmuth-Front.
Klitschivka ist so ein bisschen so ein Schlüsselort, um den es sich seit Wochen
lang dreht, beziehungsweise eine jetzt leicht nach Osten gedrückte Frontlinie
dort entlang einer Eisenbahnlinie, wo sich die Russen sehr stark eingegraben hatten.
Da feiern die Ukrainer schon Erfolge insofern, als dass sie dort vorankommen,
aber wir reden hier wirklich um hunderte von Metern pro Woche und wenige Kilometer,
die halt hier vorangeschritten wurde innerhalb dieser letzten Wochen.
Und man kann sich natürlich fragen, okay, was soll das jetzt alles?
Aber das ist halt einfach ein Teil dieser Abnutzungsstrategie und den Russen
ist es halt sehr wichtig, diese Stellung dort zu halten.
Nicht, weil sie militärisch eine besondere Bedeutung hätten,
sondern vor allem, weil es hier um Bachmut geht.
Weil das ist sozusagen ihr Propagandaerfolg gewesen, also ihr scheinbarer Propagandaerfolg,
diese Stadt genommen und dabei
halt auch komplett zerstört zu haben und diesen Standort zu verlieren,
das ist halt sozusagen für die Russen überhaupt nicht denkbar und von daher weiß,
dass die Ukraine, dass das für die Russen so ein Schmerzpunkt wäre und deswegen
fällt es ihnen relativ leicht, hier Druck auszuüben und eben auch die Truppen
zu fixieren, damit sie eben nicht woanders kämpfen können.
Wie zum Beispiel eben im Süden. Kommen wir dann auf diese Südlinie,
also das was dann wirklich von Ost nach West verläuft bis zum Libro.
Hier gibt es dann eben den einen Schwerpunkt um Willika Nowosilka,
wo es am Anfang, sozusagen als die Offensive nach Süden losging,
so einer der Schwerpunkte war.
Da ist jetzt nicht mehr so richtig viel passiert, nur auch hier kontinuierliches
Stellungsgekämpfe, um irgendwie in irgendeiner Form zu schauen,
wo kann man hier vorstoßen, wo ergeben sich unter Umständen Schwachpunkte.
Das kann ja immer sein, wenn die Aufmerksamkeit woanders ist,
dass dann eben nicht aufgepasst wird und dass man irgendwo Stellungen nicht
ausreichend besetzt hat, wo sich dann unter Umständen so eine Vorstoßmöglichkeit bietet.
Ich denke das ist so ein typischer Ort hier. Aber die Hauptaktivität,
die ist definitiv da in dem Bereich Orichiv, Robotine.
Das ist also ungefähr so 50 Kilometer vom Dnieprobecken westlich und dort ist
es eben der Vorstoß auf die Stadt Tokmak, der den Russen am meisten Sorgen bereitet.
Deswegen gehen alle Verstärkungen oder sehr viele Verstärkungen in diesem Bereich.
Das heißt die Russen werfen alles dagegen, um hier den Vorstoß der Ukraine in
irgendeiner Form in den Griff zu bekommen.
Das gelingt ihnen so halbwegs dahingehend, als dass die Fortschritte langsam
sind der Ukraine, aber sie sind kontinuierlich.
Und auch in den letzten vier, fünf Wochen sind dort verschiedene Vorstöße erreicht worden.
Ich glaube, als wir das letzte Mal darüber gesprochen haben,
gesagt, dass sie quasi hier sich langsam an dieser Suruvikin-Linie breit machen,
das ist diese Absperrgrenze, die die Russen aufgebaut haben,
die aus diesen Betonpyramiden besteht und diesen Panzergräben etc.
Das ist jetzt mittlerweile klar und offiziell, dass die überschritten wurde,
zumindest über eine bestimmte Fläche.
Und in den letzten Wochen ging es eben vor allem darum, in diesem Bereich weitere
Geländemannnahmen vorzunehmen und die Ukraine ist jetzt so drauf und dran,
alle Höhenpositionen eingenommen zu haben.
Also ich hab so den Eindruck, die Russen müssten hier schon wirklich sehr viel
dagegen schmeißen, was sie auch tun, um die Stellung noch lange halten zu können,
aber das sieht halt nicht so gut aus. Und warum ist das so wichtig?
Wichtig ist es, weil einfach Tokmak ist so das Ziel.
Nicht unbedingt die Stadt selber, sondern wenn es gelingt die Straßen nach Tokmak
abzuschneiden, das würde die Russen in diesem gesamten Bereich doch extrem schwächen.
Und ja, der Kampf findet hier eben weiterhin auf vielen Ebenen statt.
Es gibt halt unmittelbar an der Front, gibt es halt vor allem infanteriegetriebene Kämpfe,
wir erinnern uns, da sind Minenfelder, da sind Gräben, Schützengräben ohne Ende,
ja komplexe Tunnelsysteme, die dort auch ausgehoben wurden, auch in den Wäldern
oder in diesen Waldstreifen zwischen den großen Agrarfeldern, die es dort gibt.
Und das ist halt einfach ein schmerzhafter,
langsamer Waldlauf um hier in irgendeiner Form Fortschritte zu erzielen,
aber parallel dazu ändert sich so ein bisschen das Kräfteverhältnis zwischen
der Ukraine und Russland im Bereich der Artillerie.
Und das hat damit zu tun, dass die Russen einfach ein zunehmendem Maß an Problemen
haben Artillerie heranzuschaffen, also Munition.
Also da sieht es zunehmend schlecht aus für die Russen, die also wirklich Probleme
haben Nachschub zu bekommen.
Und man kann das sagen, weil natürlich die Gesamtbeobachtung der Frontlinie
auch solche Statistiken erhebt mit, okay wie viele Explosionen werden jetzt
pro Tag wo gemessen, wie viele Brände gibt es etc.
Und so die Schätzungen, die ich gesehen habe, liegen so bei,
dass die Russen nur noch 20 Prozent von dem täglich verfeuern,
was sie so im letzten Jahr verfeuert haben.
Und da die ganze russische Kraft im Wesentlichen auf Artillerie aufgebaut ist,
ist das schon ein relativ deutliches Zeichen.
Sprich, Ukraine ist mittlerweile fast schon stärker in dem Bereich der Artillerie
und wo sie auf jeden Fall einen Vorteil haben ist, dass sie genauer schießen können.
Dass sie die besseren Artilleriesysteme haben, Cäsar, Panzerhaubit 2000,
weitere amerikanische Modelle, diese 777 und zwar, das hatten wir auch alles
in den letzten Monaten immer mal wieder erwähnt.
Also sie haben einfach gute und im Idealfall auch besser gewartete Systeme, dazu bessere Munition.
Die Ukraine ist ja im Prinzip die ganze Zeit schon im Prozess zunehmend auf
NATO-Technik umzusteigen, von der alten russischen Technik.
Und das zeigt sich jetzt gepaart mit einer immer besseren Reconnaissance durch ihre Drohnenarmee,
dass sie einfach die Stellungen besser finden und in der Lage sind,
relativ zielgerichtete Artillerie gegen Panzer, gegen Flugabwehrstellungen und
vor allem gegen Artilleriegeschütze vorzunehmen.
Und das zerbröselt einfach diese Widerstandslinie der Russen langsam,
aber wie ich finde, auf eine sichtbare Art und Weise.
Also sehen kann man es schon, dass sozusagen jetzt die Offensive insgesamt,
wenn man sich das einfach mal anschaut, kann man zum Beispiel auf Deep State
Map kann man das einfach mal durchklicken und sich einfach mal angucken,
ja, wie das wirklich Stück für Stück vorangegangen bist im letzten halben Jahr.
Also so lange läuft die Offensive ja fast schon. So, also 4-5 Monate ungefähr.
Kann man da ganz gut zurück gucken und
sieht dann wo es dann begonnen hat und dass das tatsächlich ja die Ukrainer
die russischen Stellungen angeknabbert haben und ja wie dann entsprechend verstärkt
wurde von den Russen und so, das kann man ganz gut sehen.
Weil Deep State, also muss man dazu sagen, Deep State Map Punkt Live,
das ist eben so diese Karte, wo dieser Frontverlauf eben auch chronologisch
gut nachvollziehbar ist,
eben weil es eben dieses Zeit-Tool gibt und wo dann halt immer die gesicherten
und eroberten Bereiche und die Grey Zones,
also da wo beide Gruppen sozusagen nix zu sagen haben, beide Kampfparteien ganz
gut markiert sind, aber auch so die Truppenpositionierung, also wo haben die,
also die Russen zumindest, sind dort eingezeichnet. die ukrainischen Truppen
sind nicht eingezeichnet.
Ja und das ist in der Tat ganz anschaulich und da sieht man,
der Fortschritt ist da, aber er ist langsam und sicherlich ist er auch langsamer
als es sich die Ukrainer selbst erhofft haben,
als sie von ihrer Frühjahrsoffensive gesprochen haben im letzten Winter,
die ja dann eine Sommeroffensive wurde und die vielleicht ein bisschen anders gedacht war,
die dann schnell in diesen Minenfeldern erstmal Probleme bekommen hat und die
sich dann gewandelt hat auf eben diese Infanterie basierte Fortschritte,
um durch diese dichten Felder durchzukommen und das dauert natürlich länger,
aber die Fortschritte sind da und vor allem,
auch wenn wir quasi immer noch sehen, okay das ist aber jetzt hier bis zum Meer
ist ja noch relativ weit weg,
das könnte man sozusagen so erstmal denken,
also ich glaube der Frontverlauf ist jetzt irgendwie, was haben wir da,
die Front ist ungefähr so 85 Kilometer vom Meer weg.
Aber da müssen sie halt auch nicht unbedingt hin, sondern es reicht eben strategische,
oder es wäre ein großer Fortschritt, wenn sie eben strategische Versorgungslinien durchbrechen können.
Und so sind sie zum Beispiel zu dieser Straße, die von Berdyansk nach Tokmak
führt, die so eine dieser wichtigen Dinger sind, gerade mal 26 Kilometer entfernt.
Und das liegt auch schon in ihrem Artilleriebereich und sie zerstören auch größere
Barragen von Panzern, BMPs, Truppentransportern etc.
Versorgungsfahrzeugen, die so um Tokmak herum liegen. Also gerade vorgestern
haben sie da irgendwie, glaube ich 5, 6 auf einmal erledigt.
Also das ist sozusagen etwas, was stattfindet und daraus kann man eigentlich
auch ableiten, dass es alles jetzt so schlecht nicht läuft, auch wenn es besser laufen könnte.
Woran das dann im Einzelnen immer liegt, da kann man jetzt lange drüber fachsimpeln.
Machen wir vielleicht auch noch. Ja.
Also die Erwartungen zumindest waren doch etwas größer, sag ich mal,
als das was sich bisher eingestellt hat. Kann man vielleicht mal so zwischenbilanzieren.
So, dann sollte man aber jetzt nochmal schauen, dass es auch noch einen weiteren
Konfliktherd gibt und der ist in dem Sinne ja keine Frontlinie.
Das ist nochmal so ein Krieg im Krieg, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Und das ist die ganze Auseinandersetzung um die Krim, immerhin so das erklärte
Hauptziel der Ukraine, die Krim wieder zu erlangen. Und ich denke,
das wäre dann auch schon so der moralische Gewinn, wenn das irgendwann mal dann auch stattfinden wird.
Hier war ja die Bedrohung vor allem die, dass die Russen eben mit ihrer Schwarzmeerflotte
in Sevastopol relativ große Bedrohungen für die Ukraine dargestellt haben.
Und zwar einerseits, weil sie eben dort von verschiedensten Schiffen und U-Booten
diese Long-Range-Raketen abgeschossen haben. und das teilweise wohl auch immer noch tun.
Andererseits natürlich über diese Schiffe auch Versorgungslinien durchgeführt werden,
also da wird natürlich auch Material transportiert, Waffen, keine Ahnung,
was auch immer, mit entsprechenden Landesschiffen, von denen so ungefähr 809 dort im Einsatz sind.
Und natürlich geht auch eine Bedrohung von den Booten aus,
weil es natürlich einerseits die Ukrainer davon abhält, aufs Land vorzudringen von der See,
andererseits ist es auch eine Bedrohung für den Schifffahrtsverkehr,
speziell eben zu den Getreidehäfen von Odessa und die zwei, drei anderen Häfen,
die es ja dort noch an der Schwarzmeerküste der Ukraine gibt.
Und wir hatten die Auseinandersetzung mit diesem Getreidedeal ja auch schon besprochen.
Der ist halt nach wie vor nicht existent. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch keinen
weiteren geben. Das heißt, die offizielle Position der Russen ist,
Hier fährt keiner lang und wir schießen alle ab.
Aber das hat jetzt nicht so gut funktioniert in den letzten Wochen,
denn die Ukraine hat sich hier technisch interessant weiterentwickelt und hat
den Russen auf eine Art und Weise zugesetzt, dass es schon richtig schmerzt.
Was passiert?
Also wir hatten ja schon mal diese Wasserdrohnen, also diese autonom fahrenden
Boote mit Kameras ausgerüstet,
die quasi so einen Livestream liefern, sodass die also wirklich mit Sprengstoff
besetzt in die Kerzbrücke reingefahren sind,
in Schiffe, in Häfen, in Sevastopol, sogar auch in Novorossiysk,
also ihr auf russischem Gebiet liegenden Hafen an der Schwarzmeerküste und in
zunehmendem Maße diese Häfen und die Schiffe bedroht haben damit.
Da gab es dann verschiedenste Versuche, die abzuschießen, was auch teilweise
gelungen ist, aber es ist auch nicht die einzige Bedrohung.
Dazu kam jetzt in der letzten Zeit, dass es auch wirklich den Ukrainern gelungen
ist mit Booten und jetzt sogar mit Jetskis tatsächlich Landungen an der Krimküste vorzunehmen,
dort Ziele anzugreifen, also Personal, Flugabwehrstellungen,
diese zu zerstören, dann wieder Ruf aufs Boot und wieder weg.
Warum ist das möglich? Man fragt sich so, aha, wir haben ja irgendwie 180 Kilometer
bis Odessa, wie können die mit dem Jetski da auftauchen? Das ist wirklich eine gute Frage.
Und die Antwort ist noch nicht so ganz klar, nur, also es ist auch definitiv
passiert, es gibt davon Bildmaterial.
Die Ukrainer haben unter anderem die Bohrinseln, ehemalige ukrainische Bohrinseln
im schwarzen Meer wieder zurückerobert, die die Russen in 2014 weggenommen hatten.
Damit sind sie nur noch 100 Kilometer von der Küste entfernt.
Ob das schon die einzige Antwort ist auf die Frage, weiß ich nicht,
weil 100 Kilometer über Wasser ist jetzt auch nichts, was du mal eben mit dem Jetski machst.
Nur das mag eine Kombination sein aus anderen Schnellbooten,
aus denen die dann wieder starten, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Tatsache ist, diese Angriffe finden statt, zusätzlich zu diesen Wasserdrohnen.
Und was halt noch viel wichtiger ist, ist, dass es der Ukraine in den letzten
Wochen gelungen ist, gezielt zahlreiche Flugabwehrstellungen Einerseits zu zerstören.
Also auch die modernere S-400 Flugabwehrsysteme sind dort hops gegangen,
aber vor allem auch durch eine gezielte Angriffsplanung strategisch zu überlasten.
Dann sieht es so aus, dass eben erstmal eine Welle von kleineren Drohnen losgeschickt
wird, die an vielen Stellen angreift, sodass die Flugabwehr beschäftigt ist.
Und ist ja so, Flugabwehr denkt man sich immer so, okay da steht dann was und
das kann die ganze Zeit ballern, aber so ist ja auch nicht.
Die müssen ja auch irgendwie mit Raketen beladen werden und wenn die Raketen
alle verschossen sind, dann dauert es erstmal wieder eine Weile,
bis die dann auch wieder einsatzfähig sind. Ähnlich geht ja auch Russland gegen die Ukraine vor.
Nur gelingt es der Ukraine ganz gut, weil sie offensichtlich eine Drohnenproduktion
mittlerweile aufgebaut haben,
wo sie also wirklich mit großen und sehr einfach billig zu bauenden Drohnen
vorgehen können und einfach die ganze Flugabwehr so weit beschäftigen,
dass dadurch weitere Kanäle frei werden.
Das heißt, das geht dann erstmal los, die erste Front von Drohnen fliegt los,
dann geht die Luftabwehr los und dann sehen die Ukrainer sehr schnell so,
ah ok, da steht also eure Luftabwehr heute.
Dann werden da spezielle Luftabwehr-Zerstörungsraketen hingeschickt,
teilweise die Luftabwehr ausgeschaltet.
Aber über andere Trajektorien, dann eben auch über lenkbare Waffen,
fliegen dann sozusagen die eigentlichen, wirklich bedrohlichen Raketen,
wie zum Beispiel die Storm Shadow, die fliegen dann quasi etwas später rein
und die Luftabwehr ist im Prinzip nicht mehr in der Lage, hier was dagegen zu tun. Der größte...
Erfolg in diesem Bereich war der Angriff auf das Trocken-Dock des Hafens in Sevastopol.
Also das ist sozusagen ein nicht schwimmendes Trocken-Dock, sondern ein Trocken-Dock
quasi auf dem Hafengelände.
Das sind halt die wirklich großen, wichtigen Trocken-Dock-Flächen,
wo eben Schiffe gewartet und vor allem repariert werden.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt des Angriffs lag dort sowohl ein Schiff ihrer Landeflotte,
als auch ein U-Boot der Russen in diesem Trocken-Dock und es ist gelungen im
Rahmen dieses groß angelegten Angriffs,
der eben so ähnlich funktioniert hat, wie ich das gerade beschrieben habe,
mindestens, glaube ich, mit drei Storm Shadows durchzukommen.
Und je nachdem, wen man so glauben möchte, gab's 10 und 7 sind abgeschossen
worden oder die anderen 7 waren gar keine Stormshadows.
Also ich hab eher so den Eindruck, alles was sie an Stormshadow verschickt haben
ist auch angekommen und die sind halt mega präzise und nach ein,
zwei Tagen sind dann auch diverse Fotos geleakt worden, wie es dann aussah und
das Ergebnis war, sowohl dieses U-Boot als auch dieses Landesschiff ist einfach Toast.
Zentral getroffen worden, dicke Löcher in der Außenhaut und vor allem haben
sie tagelang gebrannt und das bedeutet,
dass halt nicht nur diese Schiffe und das U-Boot im Eimer ist,
sondern im Prinzip ist das ganze Trockendock im Eimer, weil da liegen jetzt
irgendwie Schiffe, die sie nicht einfach rausfahren können.
Das wird ewig dauern, bis sie das alles weggefahren und repariert bekommen,
sodass eben ihnen jetzt nicht nur diese Schiffe fehlen, sondern vor allem die
Möglichkeit, weitere Schiffe zu reparieren, was also sie wirklich doppelt und dreifach trifft.
Das tat auf jeden Fall weh und...
BK'IN DR. SCHÄUBLE Es verringert natürlich enorm den Nutzen der Krim,
also der Grund eigentlich, warum sie die Krim besetzt haben oder warum ihnen die so wichtig ist,
unter anderem ist halt natürlich von dort aus mit der Flotte operieren zu können,
also jetzt militärisch und ja, derzeit sieht es so aus, dass sie ihre Schiffe
da einfach nicht schützen können, sondern die halt woanders hinbringen müssen.
Genau, die liegen jetzt nämlich alle in Noworossijsk. Also die große Schwarzmeerflotte,
das Pfund der Russen eigentlich in diesem Gebiet, können sie derzeit nicht ausspielen,
weil sie einfach Gefahr laufen, alles zu verlieren.
Das ist für die einfach richtig teuer, weil diese Schiffe, also nicht nur,
dass die viel gekostet haben, die kriegst du auch nicht mal so eben nachproduziert.
Also das ist halt einfach null drin, hier in inmenswerter Zeit irgendetwas produzieren zu können.
Und nachdem sie schon die große Moskwa, also ihr Hauptschiff der Flotte,
verloren haben und dann eben noch so zwei, drei andere Boote,
jetzt eben auch noch ein U-Boot und zahlreiche kleinere Patrouilleboote und
was sonst noch so bei drauf ging bei diesen ganzen Angriffen,
tut's halt mittlerweile so weh und vor allem ist ja auch nicht so,
dass du immer alle Schiffe benutzen kannst.
Also viele sind ja auch in so einem Wartungszyklus und sowohl der Wartungszyklus ist jetzt durch,
als eben auch noch dann alle Schiffe, die sozusagen gerade nicht repariert werden
können und das hat jetzt so ein Grad erreicht,
wo man fast sagen kann, der Ukraine, also einem Land ohne Navy ist es quasi
gelungen eine andere Navy weitgehend in Schach zu halten.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass sie sie jetzt komplett zerstört und ausgeschaltet
haben, aber sie ist sozusagen schwerwiegend in ihrer Kernfunktion blockiert.
So sehr, dass jetzt sogar schon Getreideschiffe wieder von Odessa den Hafen
verlassen können und mühelos es bis zur Türkei schaffen.
Ja, zwar nicht, wenn man sich das anguckt auf Marine Traffic,
laden die meisten Schiffe immer noch in Rumänien ein mittlerweile da,
beziehungsweise benutzen dort dann eben die Donau.
Aber man kann so drei bis fünf Schiffe ungefähr am Tag sehen,
die dann den Weg auch nach Odessa sich trauen, Also große Getreidefrachter.
Und ja, das ist halt Realität, die man da direkt beobachtet.
Täglich beobachten kann.
Also das wird nicht ausreichen für die Ukraine, um all ihr Getreide abzufahren.
Zusätzlich gibt es ja neue Deals mit Häfen in Griechenland, in Kroatien etc.
Und wahrscheinlich auch in Rumänien.
Ja und Polen auch.
Polen auch, genau.
Nachdem die im Wahlkampf so ein bisschen Getöse gemacht hatten und das da nach
einem Konflikt aussah, hat man sich jetzt dort auch wohl darauf geeinigt in diesen Ländern,
dass die Getreidezüge jetzt direkt durchfahren können,
nicht mehr an der Grenze kontrolliert werden und eigentlich gar nicht einreisen in dem Sinne,
sondern direkt zum Zollhafen fahren und das Getreide gar nicht in die EU eingeführt
wird im Prinzip, sondern direkt raus geht.
Transitroute sozusagen.
So verstehe ich das zumindest genau, weil es nämlich Ärger gab damit,
dass halt das Getreide ja natürlich von Händlern in der EU aufgekauft wurde
und dann ja den heimischen Bauern dann Konkurrenz gemacht hat und das wollte
man jetzt damit so ein bisschen umgehen oder ausschließen.
Es hat natürlich auch noch eine technische Komponente, von der ich ehrlich gesagt
gerade noch nicht weiß, wie die eigentlich gelöst wurde. Man muss sich ja klar
machen, das ukrainische Eisenbahnsystem folgt ja dem russischen Spurstandard.
Das heißt, sie haben nicht den EU-Track, sondern sie haben halt breitere Reifenabstände,
Radabstände und können also sozusagen mit ihren normalen Zügen jetzt mal nicht
eben nach Kroatien fahren.
Ja, das ist eine interessante Frage.
Also es muss halt umgeladen werden. Die Frage ist wo wird umgeladen?
Hat die Ukraine sozusagen jetzt neue Umladestationen gebaut,
wo sie schnell von dem einen auf das andere Wagensystem umsteigen können?
Wer stellt diese anderen Züge bereit?
Wo ist unter Umständen noch ein Lückenschluss durchgezogen worden,
um sozusagen neue Übergangskapazitäten auch zu schaffen an den Grenzen?
Das sind alles so Fragen, denen müssen wir nochmal genauer nachgehen,
aber das ist in irgendeiner Form auf dem Weg.
Weil sonst würden sie ja diese Deals nicht machen. Also sie brauchen keinen
großen Deal, um jetzt über Thessaloniki und andere griechische Häfen Getreide
zu versenden, wenn sie gar nicht die Kapazität haben, das Zeug da in nennenswerten
Mengen aufschlagen zu lassen.
Ich denke mal, das ist etwas, was in den nächsten Monaten passieren wird,
sodass es dann eben im nächsten Jahr auf jeden Fall auch eine echte Ergänzung
ist in dem Besenden der Welt.
Wenn nicht, sogar die Situation generell dann nochmal verbessert hat im Schwarzen Meer.
Um die Krim-Situation noch abzuschließen, wir haben ja jetzt gesagt,
welche Nadelstiche, mit ziemlich großen Nadeln die Ukraine den Russen dort schon verabreicht hat,
aber to top it all off, gab es letzte Woche einen mega krassen Angriff erst
auf ein sekundäre Kommandozentrale der Schwarzmeerflotte.
Das heißt, da gab es in der Nähe von Silvastopol so ein Gebäude,
von dem halt angenommen wurde, dass es sozusagen so eine Ausweichkommandozentrale
ist. Die wurde beschossen.
Und während sich die Russen da noch geschüttelt haben, traf es dann wenige Tage
später die Hauptkommandozentrale der Schwarzmeerflotte.
Und offensichtlich, und das war dann auch ausnahmsweise mal kein Angriff in der Nacht,
wie das meistens der Fall ist, sondern das war ein Angriff am helligsten Tag,
ist auch sehr schön mitgefilmt worden von verschiedenen Umstehenden,
man sieht also so richtig wie so die Storm Shadow Raketen mehrfach in dieses
Gebäude reinballern und das also im Wesentlichen komplett obliteraten.
Und ja sieht so aus als ob es zu diesem Zeitpunkt ein Treffen der ganzen Schwarzmeerführung
dort gab und dabei soll nach ukrainischen Angaben ein Großteil der Führung der
Schwarzmeerflotte hops gegangen sein einschließlich des führenden Admirals.
Ja, Viktor Sokolov, genau, soll irgendwie verletzt oder getötet worden sein
und irgendwie ist es immer noch unklar.
Aber was halt passiert ist, ist, dass es in Russland eine Kampagne gegen ihn gegeben hat,
sozusagen eine Art Rufmordkampagne in den russischen Medien,
nachdem der Anschlag oder nachdem er ja tot oder lebendig oder je nachdem so und,
Die Vermutung ist jetzt, ja,
dass er vermutlich schon verletzt ist oder getötet wurde,
aber so er ist aus meiner Sicht so oder so toast, weil er auch letztlich der
Verantwortliche ist dafür, dass dieser Angriff passiert ist und dass diese Leute
dort versammelt waren und so.
Selbst wenn er davon gekommen ist, dürfte er zumindest der Rufmordkampagne nach
zu urteilen, keine Zukunft mehr in der russischen Schwarzmeerflotte haben.
Das Ganze wird ja noch ein bisschen lustiger dadurch, weil es gab dann erstmal,
also kurz danach, also ein, zwei Tage danach hat die Ukraine gesagt,
so ja, haben wir getroffen und wir sind uns relativ sicher, hier, der ist tot.
Das war sozusagen die Aussage und ich würde mal meinen, Ukraine hat da auch gute Quellen.
Dann gab es aber von der russischen Seite gar nichts. Also es wurde natürlich
in den Medien überhaupt nicht, dieser Angriff wurde gar nicht groß thematisiert.
Er ließ sich jetzt nicht komplett leugnen, dass da was stattgefunden hat,
weil dafür gab es einfach viel zu viele Bilder davon.
Aber man hat sich zu Sokolow nicht geäußert. Dann gab es aber so ein Treffen
mit Putin im Fernsehen mit den Generalen und die machen ja immer diese Meetings,
wo dann irgendwie so alle Generäle dann irgendwie so zoommäßig mit eingeblendet
werden bei solchen Remote Meetings und siehe da,
auch da war Admiral Sokolow da, war die ganze Zeit zu sehen über einen längeren
Zeitraum, hat aber keinen Ton gesagt, hatte irgendwie so ein komisches Kissen im Rücken.
Also der sah so aus als ob er irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
Totenbett würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, also er war schon sichtlich am Leben
so, aber es war so etwas skurril, also man hat das Gefühl er wird gefilmt und
er wartet eigentlich darauf, dass das Meeting irgendwie anfängt und grübelt
nochmal irgendwas nach.
Wird aber nicht angesprochen sagt nichts und natürlich gibt es keinerlei Hinweis
darauf von wann diese Aufnahme denn wirklich ist also ob das jetzt wirklich
ein live Bild von ihm war und er dann noch gelebt hat oder ob das sozusagen
einfach so Material ist was sie noch rumliegen lassen das wir einfach mit reingeschnitten haben,
würde gut passen sozusagen zur russischen Propaganda und das ist auch ehrlich
gesagt so ein bisschen meine Vermutung und jetzt,
Weil sie ja irgendwie irgendwann auch mal zugeben müssen,
dass er dann doch nicht mehr lebt, bauen sie jetzt sozusagen an dieser Legende
auf mit er wäre ja irgendwie korrupt und so weiter und er hätte ja viele Feinde
und wahrscheinlich werden wir dann in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen irgendwann hören,
wie er von irgendjemand umgebracht worden ist oder keine Ahnung bei irgendeinem
Unfall ums Leben gekommen ist oder aus dem Fenster gestürzt,
was halt so normalerweise passiert.
Und das war es dann halt. Bloß nicht zugeben, dass die Ukraine eben durch einen
Luftschlag und das auch noch mit westlichen Raketen,
was sie ja auch die ganze Zeit vermeiden, weil sie ja immer gesagt haben,
Ja ne, wenn hier westliche Raketen die Krim angreifen und so weiter,
dann ist ja Dritter Weltkrieg.
So, das macht ja aber die Ukraine schon die ganze Zeit so und dann, ja.
Doch erstmal kein dritter Weltkrieg ausgerufen worden von den Russen,
also jenseits ihrer üblichen Propaganda meine ich.
Ja und dann glaube ich ist das sozusagen so ein bisschen ihre Strategie,
die jetzt noch nicht komplett abgeschlossen ist.
Also auf jeden Fall, üblicherweise ist ja diese ganze russische Propaganda sehr
albern, wenn auch bedrohlich, wenn man sich das so anschaut,
aber auf der Krim haben sie einfach gerade ein echtes Problem.
Die ganze Flotte ist quasi nicht mehr benutzbar, nur noch in Teilen.
Die Luftabwehr wird die ganze Zeit weiter dezimiert.
Macht den Rüssen nur so ein bisschen was aus, weil da haben sie sehr viel Nachschub
noch. Also sie besitzen sehr viele von diesen Flugabwehrsystemen,
aber es ist natürlich auch was anderes, wenn gerade so deine Topmodelle getroffen
werden und dann musst du auch erstmal wieder was hinbringen,
dann musst du es irgendwie platzieren und so weiter.
Das ist alles nicht gut und von daher haben sie dort eine schlechte Zeit und
die Ukraine macht Fortschritte, auch wenn das natürlich für den Kriegsverlauf
so erstmal keine unmittelbare Bedeutung hat.
Übrigens noch Ergänzung, dieser Angriff auf das Militärhauptquartier,
auf der Krim, hatte den Namen Crab Trap, also sozusagen Krabbenfalle oder wie auch.
Ja, dann gucken wir mal, ja, achso ja genau,
es gibt ja dann noch einen weiteren Aspekt und zwar abgesehen von dem Frontkampf,
von dem Auseinandersetzung auf der Krim, gibt es auch in zunehmendem Maße Drohnenangriffe
und Raketenangriffe auf russisches Gebiet.
Und da explodiert immer mal wieder irgendwas. Es gab jetzt nicht so viel Angriffe
fern der Grenze, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Also es sind Städte getroffen
worden, so im 100 Kilometer Range.
Aber in den Wochen davor gab es auch einige spektakuläre Angriffe auf Flugzeuglandeplätze,
Flughäfen, wo militärisches Gerät herumstand.
Teilweise sogar bis kurz vor die baltischen Staaten. Ich weiß nicht ob wir das
in der letzten Sendung schon behandelt hatten diese Angriffe. Ich glaube ja.
Davon gab es vereinzelte weitere Angriffe. Also es sind immer mal wieder Flugzeuge
zerstört worden. Es gab auch Angriffe zum Beispiel auf eine Hubschrauberlandebasis in Sochi.
Also auch sehr tief im russischen Gebiet. Ein bisschen dieses und das.
Also auch der Druck wird von der Ukraine aufrechterhalten und es macht auch
so den Eindruck, dass sie eben dort weitere technische Fortschritte erzielen,
weil sie halt einfach eine Drohnenproduktion angestoßen haben, large scale.
Also sie bauen unterschiedlichste Drohnen, also von Quadrokoptern bis Langstrecken
Drohnen unterschiedlicher Couleur und das ist so eine ihrer Aufrüstungsstrategien, die sie haben.
Haben diese aus dem eigenen Land heraus leisten können.
Es gab im Übrigen auch einen kleinen Angriff auf eine russische Trafostation,
die dann kurzerhand mal das Licht in Strom ausgeknipst hat in einer russischen
Stadt und geht davon aus,
dass der dem Zweck diente, so Russland zu signalisieren,
naja, wenn ihr vorhabt im im Winter wieder unser Stromnetz zu bombardieren,
das können wir im Übrigen auch.
Das heißt, da hat die Ukraine durchaus jetzt auch signalisiert,
dass sie den kommenden Winter,
wenn Russland wieder versucht, Stromnetz und Heizung und so anzugreifen,
dass die Ukraine dann im Winter Gleiches auf russischer Seite tun wird.
BINBIN ICH NICHT SO SICHER, OB DAS DIE RUSSEN VON IRGENDWAS ABHALTEN WIRD,
ABER ES KANN DURCHAUS SEIN, DASS IHRE STRATEGIE DAHINGEHEND AUSGELEGT IST.
JA, ALSO JEDENFALLS WISSEN SIE, WISSEN SIE JETZT BESCHEID, SO ZUMINDEST,
ALSO DIE UKRAINE HAT BESCHEID GESAGT.
GENAU, DEFINITIV.
Ja, ansonsten gab es noch verschiedene Nachrichten über Bauaktivitäten Russlands,
also einmal über neue Schnellstraßen und Bahnstrecken in den besetzten Gebieten,
vor allen Dingen irgendwo Donbass, die wohl teilweise dem Militär vorbehalten sein sollen,
damit die dann eine eigene Straße haben, wo sie, ohne anhalten zu müssen oder
langsam fahren zu müssen,
einfach durchbrettern können, um es den Drohnen schwieriger zu machen oder generell,
je schneller natürlich so ein Fahrzeug fährt, umso schwieriger ist es auch,
das dann mit Artillerie zu treffen.
Und vor einigen Monaten schon wurde auch gemeldet, dass so neue Siedlungen,
nicht nur auf der Krim, sondern auch in Mariupol wurden so zehn schicke neue
Wohnblöcke fertiggestellt beispielsweise.
Aber da kam jetzt raus, dass die Qualität der Bauten wohl so ein bisschen problematisch
ist. in einem dieser Neubauten.
In Mariupol läuft wohl jetzt seit Wochen ein Kellergeschoss voll mit Abwasser,
also mit Scheiße und niemand repariert es und das stinkt wohl ziemlich bis zum Himmel.
Also ja, das ist dann ein bisschen die Situation, weil die haben viel Propaganda
gemacht und die sehen auch von außen wirklich schick aus, die Bauten.
Klar, eine Leitung kann immer mal irgendwo reißen,
aber dass dann, sagen Sie, sich niemand drum kümmert und dann,
ja, dass seit Wochen dort im Prinzip das Abwasser sich ins Kellergeschoss ergießt
aus diesen nagelneuen Wohnblöcken, das ist schon wieder sehr russisch.
Ja ich meine mit den Straßen ist ganz interessant, was aus meiner Perspektive
für sie natürlich wirklich Sinn machen würde, wäre eben der Bau einer Südlinie der Eisenbahn.
Mich wundert das ohnehin, wenn ich mir das Eisenbahnnetz der Ukraine anschaue,
was ja für die Ukraine auch schon immer wichtig war, dass es zum Beispiel zwischen
Berdjansk und Mariupol, also am Asowschen Meer entlang, keinerlei Bahnverbindungen gibt.
Stattdessen müssen dann die
Bahnen immer nach Norden, um dann wieder irgendwie nach Süden abzudrehen.
Das mag irgendwelche geografischen, vielleicht auch geologischen Gründe haben, die ich nicht kenne.
Aber das ist definitiv etwas, von dem ich mir denke, dass die Russen probieren
könnten. Allerdings müssen sie dann eben verschiedene Flüsse auch mit Brücken
überbauen. Und ob sie sowas in kürzester Zeit hinbekommen, da habe ich echt
meine Zweifel. BK'IN DR.
MERKEL Also sie sind dabei, wohl.
Also sie bauen. Die Frage ist, wird es überhaupt fertig werden?
Und wenn ja, welchen Zustand wird es dann haben?
Aber ich fand es zumindest interessant und erwähnenswert, dass die Russen dort
größere Bauaktivitäten auch unternehmen in den besetzten Gebieten.
Ja, ich denke, wenn dieser Krieg vorbei ist, dann wird die Ukraine wahrscheinlich
sehr schnell darauf drängen, ihre Spurweite auf europäische Breite umzustellen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie noch länger ein kompatibles System mit Russland haben wollen.
Kann gut sein. Aber es ist nicht ganz einfach.
Ja, wir haben es jetzt schon ein paar mal erwähnt. Ganz interessant,
was jetzt sozusagen technisch auch passiert.
Also es wird einiges an neuer Militärtechnik entwickelt.
Das gilt eben vor allem für diese Drohnen, also diese Drone-Army.
Das ist so ein richtig dickes Ding. Und man darf nie vergessen,
die Ukraine ist ja wirklich ein extrem findiges Land.
Und natürlich ist es auch so, wenn du ein Land bist unter Beschuss,
also ein Land im Krisenmodus, also in der echten bedrohlichen,
lebensbedrohlichen Krise, dann ja, dann...
Dann wirst du kreativ, weil dann wird natürlich alles nicht beantwortet mit
das haben wir noch nie so gemacht, sondern wird sozusagen jede Gelegenheit in
irgendeiner Form Fortschritte zu erzielen dann auch genutzt werden.
Und der ganze Technologie und Software Sektor war in der Ukraine schon immer
stark. Auch als Militärindustrie war die Ukraine ja schon immer ein Powerhouse
gewesen. Also viele der russischen Militärtechniken sind ja auch in der Ukraine
entwickelt und gebaut worden.
Und ja, den Fokus auf Drohnen haben wir ja schon erwähnt. Also die Wasserdrohnen
und vor allem die ganzen Flugdrohnen.
Aber eben auch was im Softwarebereich so abgeht, ist sehr interessant.
Hier kommt natürlich auch eine ganze Menge so Machine Learning, KI-Kram zum Einsatz.
Also es gibt Berichte von Drohnensystemen, die jetzt russische Stellungen überfliegen
und dabei eben mit solchen Machine Learning Trainiermodellen automatisch zum
Beispiel Panzer, die im Wald stehen, erkennen.
Was halt sonst nur von geübten Beobachtern, die eben live selber zuschauen,
über einen Videostream gemacht werden können.
Aber jetzt wird es halt in zunehmendem Maße möglich, Drohnen einfach autonom
losfliegen zu lassen. Die halt selber schauen, aha, okay, hier ist so ein Waldstreifen.
Also wenn man mal auf die Ukraine schaut, gerade in diesem Bereich ist ja im
Wesentlichen alles immer riesige Agrarfläche, Waldstreifen, riesige Agrarfläche, Waldstreifen.
Und Stellungen der Russen sind natürlich primär in diesen Waldstreifen.
Also der Ukraine auch, weil alles andere bietet sozusagen keinen Schutz.
Es gibt natürlich auch Ausnahmen, aber da ist es natürlich am schwersten zu
entdecken und natürlich sind gerade Artilleriesysteme, Flugabwehrsysteme etc.
Sind da natürlich an solchen Orten. Und die will man finden und wenn man Drohnen hat,
die einfach das ganze Land sozusagen automatisch abfliegen und dabei eben mit
einer Kamera nach unten in dem Moment, wo sie rüberfliegen, schon diese Standorte
ausfindig machen können.
Und dann nur noch die Koordinaten zurückmelden.
Das ist natürlich was ganz anderes, als ob da eine Person die ganze Zeit so
einen Videolivestream anschauen muss und sich selber seine Gedanken machen muss,
ob da irgendwo was ist. Wie gut das funktioniert, keine Ahnung,
weiß ich nicht. Ich kann mir das ganz gut vorstellen, dass das funktioniert. Ich denke du auch.
Und solche Systeme werden also jetzt wirklich schnell entwickelt.
Was hältst du von der Technik-Idee?
Ja, ich meine, klar, wenn es hilft,
so, und das stellt sich dann recht schnell raus und ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
ja, dass das hilft, also gerade beim Auffinden von bestimmten Fahrzeugen oder
so in bestimmten Bildmaterial,
kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das gut funktioniert oder brauchbar.
Zumindest die kennen wahrscheinlich dann nicht alle,
also Tarnung funktioniert dann trotzdem noch, aber vermutlich kann man ähnlich
gute Erkennungsraten damit erreichen, wie jemand, der da drauf guckt,
würde ich sagen, jetzt bei der Bildauswertung.
Also gibt jetzt kein Grund, warum das dann schlechter sein sollte.
Das andere, ja, was ich sehr interessant fand,
ist, dass bei der Minenräumung es dann auch unterschiedlichste Verfahren drohenbasiert
gibt, um die Minenräumung zu vereinfachen.
Und so eins davon ist, was schon wohl länger praktiziert wird,
ist, dass abends, wenn sich dann die Luft abkühlt,
man das Gelände mit einer Thermalkamera überfliegt und dann mögliche Standorte
oder Orte von größeren Minen anhand der Temperatur erkennen kann,
weil das dann dort ein bisschen langsamer abkühlt beispielsweise.
Das ist eine Variante, die andere Variante, die ich ziemlich abgefahren war, so eine große...
Agrardrohne, die dann mit einem angehängten Magnetometer das Feld abfliegt und
anhand dann der Magnetsignatur auch mit Machine Learning sozusagen so eine,
ja, Magnetmap macht und damit dann auch größere Minen, die tiefer liegen, wohl erkennen kann.
Aber generell sind so Minenräumoperationen, also da gibt es nicht so,
ja, das Silver Bullet, sondern das hängt dann auch sehr von Gelände und ja,
der spezifischen Situation ab.
Und da werden auch viele Verfahren kombiniert.
Ich jetzt gesehen habe ist, dass wenn jetzt so ein wieder,
also befreites, wiedererobertes oder befreites, vermintes Gebiet,
so ein Feld geräumt werden soll, damit der Bauer da wieder.
Drauf kann, dann versucht man zuerst die großen Panzerminen runterzukriegen
und nachdem die Panzerminen dann weg sind,
wird nochmal mit einem speziellen Gerät das Ding befahren, um dann die anderen Minen zu räumen.
Und da gibt es ein wirklich lustiges Gerät,
sag ich mal, und da gibt es einmal den eigentlichen Triebwagen,
der wo der Motor drin ist und das Bedienpersonal drin sitzt und der fährt so
ein Feld quasi im Zickzack ab und fährt immer eine Kante ab und hat einen Ausleger,
der so eine Spurbreite rüber geht und an dem Ausleger sind zwei Stahlkabel und
zieht dann so einen Minenroller hinter sich her,
aber nicht direkt hinter sich, sondern quasi links neben sich und fährt halt
so Stück für Stück das Feld ab und kann halt dann,
befährt halt das eigentliche Antriebsgerät, die Person befährt halt nur geräumtes
Gelände und der Minenroller rollt halt links daneben.
So.
Und die Kabel sind dann sozusagen auch hinter dem Fahrzeug, das heißt,
wenn die Miene los geht, ist es sozusagen hinter ihm und neben ihm.
Ja genau, hinter und neben ihm, genau. So 10, 20 Meter hinter ihm geht es dann hoch, die Miene.
Aber dieser Minenroller ist auch so, wenn da jetzt Antipersonenminen explodieren,
Das ist dann so ein bisschen wie, ja, es knallt dann so ein bisschen wie so,
ja, Firecracker, so,
und dann hüpfen, also dieser, dieser Minenroller selber besteht aus,
ich sag mal, zehn Rollen, die unabhängig voneinander sind, so jeweils,
ich weiß nicht, 20 Zentimeter breit oder so.
Und wenn dann dort was explodiert, hüpft halt dann dieser eine Ring so ein bisschen
in die Höhe oder zwei Ringe oder so von diesem Minenroller und das sieht sehr interessant aus,
wenn die sich über das Feld bewegen und auf so einen Haufen Minen stoßen.
Aber für die großen Panzerminen, ja, das übersteht dieser Art von Räumgerät
nicht unbedingt schadlos.
Das kann dann zumindest beschädigt werden, aber es passiert dann niemanden,
falls eben bei der Panzerminenräumung eine übersehen wurde.
Und diese Drohnen spielen da jetzt rein, dann eben in der Vorbereitung und Entscheidung,
welche Strategie und welches Gerät man zum Einsatz bringt und so und wo und ja.
Ja, das Demining der Ukraine, das wird natürlich nach dem Krieg eine unglaubliche Herausforderung,
beziehungsweise ist es ja jetzt auch schon, weil es ja jetzt schon sehr viele
vermiente Gebiete gibt,
die man jetzt nicht ohne weiteres wieder schon benutzen kann und da kreativ
zu werden, das ist natürlich sehr geboten und das klingt auf jeden Fall schon
mal nach einer ganz kreativen Lösung.
Ja, abgesehen von Militärtechnik, die die Ukraine sich jetzt selbst ausdenkt
oder vielleicht auch zusammen mit Partnern neu entwickelt, geht es natürlich
auch immer noch um neue Waffenlieferungen von bereits existierenden Systemen.
Hier hat sich ein bisschen was getan, zumindest was die amerikanischen Lieferungen betrifft.
Und nachdem es ja lange, lange, lange Zeit hieß, ja nee, klappt nicht,
sind jetzt wohl doch diese Attackams zugesagt worden.
Zumindest in einer bestimmten Version. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
ob wir das letzte Mal schon angesprochen haben, aber das müsste jetzt auch langsam
dann nochmal auf dem Feld zu sehen sein.
Attack Gems sind relativ massive Raketen, die passenderweise mit demselben Gerät
versendet werden können,
wie die bisherigen GLMRS Geschosse, also mit diesen HIMARS und M270 Abschussrampen,
von denen die Ukraine ja so einige hat und ich glaube bisher keine oder kaum welche verloren hat.
Und die ja für die Russen echt ein richtiger Schmerz sind.
Also Heimars hat ja einst den Krieg gewendet und trägt jetzt nach wie vor dazu
bei hier Fortschritte zu erzielen.
Mit Atacams kann man halt sehr viel weiter liegende Ziele mit sehr viel größeren Ladungen treffen.
Leider kriegt die Ukraine aber nicht die dicken Bomben sozusagen,
sondern eher so die Cluster Variante davon glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe.
Was auch praktisch ist, weil es eben für bestimmte Ziele auch sinnvoller ist,
eben so eine größere Fläche zu anzugreifen und nicht nur jetzt maximale Sprengkraft
auf einen einzigen Ort auszuliefern.
Man weiß nicht so ganz genau, was so die politischen Gründe dahinter sind,
warum es sozusagen da immer noch nicht zu einer vollumfänglichen Unterstützung
kommt, vor allem nicht aus Deutschland.
Grüße an Herrn Scholz hier. Irgendwie Taurus-Raketen könnten diesem Krieg auch
helfen, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen kriegt Deutschland mal wieder nicht den
Fuß vor den anderen gesetzt. Außerdem sind jetzt die Abrams Panzer angekommen.
Das ist jetzt bestätigt. Also die amerikanischen M1 Abrams Panzer,
die ja viel Sprit verbrauchen, aber uns schwer sind und so weiter und aus vielen
Gründen irgendwie nicht so richtig erste Wahl gewesen sind, aber die Ukraine
nimmt halt alles, was sie kriegen können.
Und selbst wenn diese Panzer jetzt für den Herbst, wo ja alles nass und feucht wird,
die nicht als Vorstoßpanzer benutzen kann direkt an der Front,
hat sich ja in letzter Zeit auch schon mit diesen Leopardpanzern das so eingespielt,
dass die im Prinzip als mobile Artillerie verwendet werden.
Also schnell irgendwo hinkommt und dann eben mit den relativ zielgenauen Dingern
mit einer entsprechenden artillerieartigen Planung halt indirect fire macht.
Also nicht direkt auf irgendwas schießt, sondern eben solche ballistischen Kurven
nutzt und damit eben auch Ziele, sagen wir mal, in so einem 20 Kilometer Range erreicht.
Das geht natürlich dann auch mit diesen Abrams Panzern. Am Ende habe ich keine
Ahnung, wie die Ukraine meint jetzt diese Panzer zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Es sind jetzt auch erstmal nicht sehr viele, aber ein Anfang ist gemacht und
da werden natürlich auch noch weitere kommen, weil wenn erstmal der erste da
ist, heißt es, die Logistik ist da,
Reparaturwissen ist da, Leute werden ausgebildet an diesen Panzern etc.
Das macht ja nur Sinn, wenn es hier auch einen kontinuierlichen Flow von Material
gibt und also sowohl von neuen Panzern als eben auch an Reparaturmaterial.
Und ich denke, wir werden dann im weiteren Verlauf dieses Krieges auch irgendwann
sehen, so ah okay, jetzt sind aber auch amerikanische Panzer zum Einsatz gekommen.
Ja und dann hatten wir das letzte Mal schon angesprochen, sind ja auch Lieferungen
von Cluster Munition schon geliefert worden, also Cluster Munition für die Artillerie.
Artillerie, also die 155 mm NATO-Standard-Artillerie-Geschosse,
da gibt es ja sehr viele unterschiedliche.
Artillerie ist nicht gleich Artillerie, also natürlich die Abschussrampen sind
immer dieselben, aber was man da reinstecken kann, da gibt es extrem unterschiedliche Modelle.
Je nachdem, was man für Ziele hat,
was man konkret angreift, welche Panzerungen man durchschlagen möchte Also es
gibt da so eine große Liste von unterschiedlichen Munitionstypen und ein Munitionstyp,
der halt vor ein, zwei Monaten dann eben zugesagt und auch geliefert und auch
zum Einsatz gekommen ist, sind eben diese Cluster-Munitions-Artilleriegranaten.
Und da gab es natürlich wieder viel Aufregung, weil ja Cluster Munition, naja, ist ja verboten.
Nur ganz so einfach ist es halt erstens nicht, zweitens, also verboten ja wo?
Also es gibt ein Abkommen einzelner Länder.
Ich weiß nicht genau wie viele es sind. Deutschland gehört auf jeden Fall dazu.
Wo man sagen wir mal in den guten Zeiten gesagt hat, das ist aber böse,
weil Cluster Munition natürlich das Problem hat, dass wenn man jetzt so,
also es sind ja quasi so, in einer Shell sind dann eben viele Bomblets.
Also man schießt die Granate los und am Ende gibt es nicht eine Explosion,
sondern es gibt viele kleine Explosionen ausgebreitet über einen großen Bereich.
Man kann sich schon vorstellen, warum das irgendwie ganz sinnvoll ist für bestimmte Ziele.
Also sogenannte weiche Ziele, sprich Menschen. Da funktioniert das natürlich
gut. Es funktioniert auch gut, wenn man sozusagen leicht zu durchschlagende
Ziele hat, sagen wir mal ganz normale LKW-Ansammlungen etc.
Infrastruktur in irgendeiner Form. Es gibt einfach militärisch betrachtet viele
Ziele, wo man sowas haben will.
Aber es gibt natürlich dann diese Nicht-Explosions-Rate, die unterschiedlich
groß ist bei den einzelnen Modellen.
Und dann liegen halt die kleinen Dinger rum und sind dann eben später nach dem
Konflikt für die Bevölkerung dort vor Ort ein Riesenproblem. Gar keine Frage.
Ja und dann gab es und gibt es auch immer noch entsprechende Diskussionen.
Wir sind das auch gefragt worden im Feedback, Kommentaren glaube ich,
so warum wir denn nicht mal diese Seite betrachten und überhaupt was erlaube
die Ukraine, dass sie solche Munition einsetzt.
Ja, also mit der ethischen Betrachtung von Waffen ist es halt generell schwierig
und in dem Fall finde ich ist es auch doppelt schwierig,
weil ich denke man muss es im Kontext betrachten und der Kontext ist halt einfach,
die Ukraine führt gerade einen Kampf um ihr Überleben.
Und selbstverständlich ist der Ukraine an der Stelle erstmal alles wichtiger,
was sozusagen wirkt, um in irgendeiner Form den russischen Angriff zurückzuschlagen.
Da ist ihr in Anführungsstrichen jedes Mittel recht.
Selbstverständlich gibt es ein Problem mit Cluster-Munition,
gar keine Frage und man hätte am liebsten keine einzige Explosion auf dem ganzen
Land gehabt, aber so ist es halt nun mal.
Aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass von diesen Abermillionen von Artillerie-Geschossen,
die die Russen in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren jetzt verschossen haben,
eineinhalb Jahren, jetzt schon eine ganze Menge Blindgänger überall sind, ja?
Die Russen haben vom ersten Tag an Streumunition eingesetzt.
Also da war halt vor allen Dingen, ja, also Amnesty International zum Beispiel schon am 25.
Februar 2022 wurde irgendwie die Stadt Oktirka mit Streumunitionen beschossen,
wo dann drei Zivilisten getötet worden sind.
Und Human Rights Watch hat hunderte von Streumunitions-Einsätzen durch Russland dokumentiert.
Insofern, also wer sich an Streumunition jetzt erst mal stört,
muss sich in erster Linie an dem russischen Einsatz von.
Streumunition an Stoß nehmen und dort, wo diese Streumunition jetzt auch von der Ukraine zumindest.
Eingesetzt wird überwiegend. Das ist halt ja gegen Truppenkonzentrationen im Frontbereich,
wo ohne Ende Minen bereits liegen und wo ja, dass das Gelände am Ende ohnehin
von Minen befreit werden muss.
Und da ist jetzt die eigene zusätzliche Cluster Munition macht da jetzt den
Kohl nicht mehr fett, so sehe ich das einfach.
Auf der anderen Seite, wie du schon auch richtig sagst, generell Waffen,
die dann gegen Menschen eingesetzt werden.
Aber der Verteidigungskrieg ist eine der wenigen Formen des gerechten Krieges, wie es so schön heißt.
Also sowohl nach UN-Standard, als auch was der Papst und die katholische Kirche sagt. Insofern, ja.
Ist das abgesegnet sozusagen?
Es ist abgesegnet.
Okay. Ja,
also ich meine ihr seht schon und ihr wisst es wahrscheinlich auch ohnehin,
weil wir nehmen eigentlich von Anfang an diese Position auch ein und ich halte
die auch nach wie vor für gerechtfertigt,
dass es, also in meinen Augen gibt es keine Argumente dafür,
dass die Ukraine sich hier in irgendeiner Form zurückhalten muss.
Ja, die werden angegriffen, es geht hier einfach ums nackte Überleben der Leute
und es geht ums nackte Überleben des gesamten Staates. Es ist das erklärte Ziel
von Russland, die Ukraine komplett zu zerstören, zu übernehmen, zu russifizieren.
Es werden dort Kinder entführt, es werden viele Leute getötet,
es wird die Infrastruktur zerstört, es wird einfach alles getan.
Das ist einfach der schlimmste Krieg, den wir hatten seit dem zweiten Weltkrieg
und wenn es so weiter geht, werden hier auch noch ein paar Rekorde gebrochen werden.
Da gibt es überhaupt keine Diskussion in meinen Augen, dass hier nicht alles
getan werden muss, um diesen Krieg zu beenden und zwar nicht um ihn jetzt irgendwie
einzufrieren, so wie er ist, sondern zu beenden im Sinne von Russland muss nach Hause gehen.
Und da können sie dann auch gerne bleiben und sich mit ihren eigenen Problemen
rumschlagen und überlegen, wie sie in den nächsten 20, 30 Jahren wieder den
Weg nach Europa finden wollen.
Das sind alles Fragen, die werden in der Zukunft noch geklärt werden müssen,
aber jetzt geht es erstmal nur darum, hier die Ukraine zu unterstützen und ehrlich
gesagt, ich schäme mich dafür, dass die Unterstützung nach wie vor lückenhaft ist.
Ich schäme mich dafür, dass wir in der EU solche Länder haben wie Ungarn,
die einfach hier überhaupt nichts tun für die Ukraine. Ganz im Gegenteil,
sich auch noch in diesen ganzen Propaganda-Strudel der Russen noch mit einbauen
lassen und keine Ahnung, was die überhaupt für eine Agenda verfolgen.
Aber das ist einfach mal wirklich schäbig. Aber eben auch was das Verhalten
von Deutschland betrifft,
muss ich sagen, ja okay gut da wird viel Geld gegeben, es werden jetzt mittlerweile
auch viele Waffen geliefert, es werden mittlerweile auch Panzer geliefert,
aber es ist halt einfach immer wieder so eine Diskussion, wo dieses Land zum
Jagen getragen werden muss.
Was ist jetzt hier mit diesen Taurus Raketen? Wozu sind die denn mal angeschafft
und gebaut worden? Wenn nicht genau für diesen Fall.
Ja.
Ja, also das ist einfach exakt der Grund, warum wir die überhaupt haben,
ist, wenn es einen Aggressor gibt, der irgendwie...
Die Grundordnung hier in Europa zerstören will.
Es ist nicht lange her, da hat Europa den Friedensnobelpreis bekommen,
die EU, weil sie ja so toll für Frieden gesorgt hat und jetzt ist das auf einmal
nicht mehr so wichtig oder was? Also das ist halt irgendwie das,
was ich nicht so richtig verstehe.
Gut, andere Länder mögen da auch ihre Defizite haben und sicherlich gibt es
in jeder Diskussion, in jedem Land eine schwierige Diskussion,
weil du natürlich nie immer alle auf deiner Seite hast und nicht jeder diese Idee hat.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Mir ist ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz klar,
warum in Deutschland man sich nicht ganz klar auf diese Seite stellt.
Es ist mir nicht, ich habe Vermutungen warum es so ist, aber verstehen kann ich es trotzdem nicht.
Ja gut, es gibt auf der einen Seite natürlich immer noch diese zweite Weltkriegsschuld,
insbesondere gegenüber Russland.
Das ist so ein Ding, was bei vielen Leuten mit rein spielt.
Oder auch dann letztlich in der Politik und gerade in der SPD,
so die ganze Brandpolitik, Annäherung, Wandel durch Handel und so.
Und die ganze Ostpolitik der Ära Brand ist ja den Bach runtergegangen jetzt.
Und irgendwie hat man Probleme, sich mit dieser Realität zu arrangieren in Deutschland.
Dann ist Deutschland ja durchaus, würde ich sagen,
ein super pazifistisches Land, aber im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern,
so eine Deutschlandflagge in den Garten oder ins Fenster zu hängen außerhalb
von Weltmeisterschaften, ist dann schon ein Ding, was einen in eine bestimmte Ecke stellt.
Während Amerikaner jeder Zweite irgendwo eine Amerika-Flagge draußen hängen
hat, ohne dass das jetzt allzu viel bedeutet.
Das ist so ein bisschen die eine Richtung und Stimmung.
Die andere ist, dass man natürlich dann nach 50 Jahren Besatzungszeit und einer Außenpolitik,
die ja sehr eingebettet war und wo man tatsächlich einfach nicht souverän war
und einfach ein Sonderfall da war und man gewisse Dinge eben verlernt hat, so.
Und außenpolitisch meine ich jetzt. Und das, habe ich das Gefühl,
spielt halt auch noch mit rein,
rein, dass man sich jedenfalls nicht vortraut und keine Führungsrolle zutraut,
das sagen immer, warten bis andere vorpreschen und eventuell geht man dann mit,
weil man will dann jetzt auch wieder nicht ganz so außen vorstehen,
aber man kann durchaus auch einen Punkt machen, dass,
es vielleicht nicht unklug sein könnte, sich zu beschränken,
jetzt aus strategischer Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Sicht, in dem man zum einen ein gewisses Eskalationspotenzial bewahrt,
und zwar auch ein glaubwürdiges, dass man immer noch einerseits was in der Hinterhand hat,
um die Russen gegebenenfalls auch davon abzuhalten, bestimmte Dinge zu tun.
Und auf der anderen Seite es auch Putin schwerer zu machen, im Land zu mobilisieren.
Im Moment gelingt es noch so einigermaßen,
die Probleme in der Ukraine,
will nicht sagen zu verheimlichen, aber doch das Ausmaß der Probleme zu verheimlichen und somit eben auch,
was die Mobilmachung angeht, beispielsweise,
sagen, dass das Russland oder dass der Wille der russischen Bevölkerung,
sich anzustrengen in dem Krieg, nicht zu sehr gestärkt wird.
Aber ja, am Ende natürlich, wenn man sich die russische Propaganda anschaut, dann wird
da seit zwei Jahren ständig mit Atomschlägen gedroht und seit zwei Jahren ist
alles furchtbar, was der Westen macht.
Und man kämpft sowieso seit zwei Jahren gegen die Nato,
also aus russischer Sicht ist ja zweite Panzer und jeder zweite Soldat aus der
NATO so ungefähr, jedenfalls was die Propaganda angeht. Habe.
Die russische Führung weiß halt genau auch, dass dem nicht so ist,
dass sie sich zwar mit westlichen Waffen abgeben müssen, aber nur wenige der
Waffen sind tatsächlich state of the art.
Im Grunde genommen, also Storm Shadow ist wahrscheinlich,
ja, Skype Storm Shadow ist wahrscheinlich so ziemlich das modernste,
was die Ukraine zur Verfügung hat an jetzt beispielsweise Artilleriesystemen.
Und dann muss man auch sagen.
Dass Deutschland mittlerweile sehr brauchbare Waffensysteme auch geliefert hat
und wenig Schrott jetzt,
nachdem man über die 5000 Helme am Anfang drüber hinweggekommen ist und den NVA-Schrott,
der war halt da und insofern kann man das jetzt auch niemandem übel nehmen in Deutschland.
Aber ja, ansonsten ist die Ukraine halt auch mit viel alten Kram einfach ausgestattet worden.
Und in dem Zusammenhang fällt auch nochmal, weil wir ja bei Cluster-Munition
eigentlich wahnfält diese cluster munition weil.
Ja, die USA, die ausgemustert hat und die nicht mehr einsetzen wird und die
eigentlich zur Verschrottung vorgesehen waren.
Deswegen, das spielte sicherlich auch eine Rolle bei der Lieferung.
Politisch hätte man es gerne vermieden, jetzt sagen diese Cluster-Munition oder
Streumunition, wie sie altdeutsch heißt.
Also wenn man genug andere Munitionen gehabt hätte und hätte,
also man hätte sicherlich jetzt nicht extra Streumunitionen neu für die Ukraine
produziert und das steht auch nicht auf dem Plan jetzt,
ja weil, aber insgesamt ja ist die für bestimmte Einsatzbereiche,
Also hilft eben die andere Munitionstypen,
andere Artilleriegranaten zu sparen und indem man bei bestimmten Operationen
dann diese Streumunition,
die eigentlich zur Verschrottung vorgesehen war, dann einsetzen kann.
Und die Ersparnis ist dann teilweise auch bei bestimmten Einsätzen nicht 1 zu
1, sondern so teilweise 3 zu 1, 5 zu 1, d.h.
Für eine Clusterartilleriegranate spart dann 3 bis 5 konventionelle Granaten
ein, was natürlich auch für die Logistik hilfreich ist. Und wenn die dann noch
vom Müll kommen, quasi, wer kann da widerstehen?
So was, oder?
Ja.
Na gut, soviel vielleicht zu dem Thema von Waffensystemen.
Jetzt wollten wir nochmal eine allgemeine Einschätzung machen.
Insbesondere jetzt konkret auf diese Offensive, die halt noch läuft,
die vielleicht auch ihren Höhepunkt so noch nicht erreicht hat.
Das ist ein bisschen schwer einzuschätzen.
Grundsätzlich wie die Ukraine aufgestellt ist, ist ja so,
sie haben halt jetzt an der Front, an verschiedenen Stellen versucht durchzustechen,
das ist ihnen jetzt halt teilweise gelungen,
wie ich schon anfangs erwähnt, vielleicht nicht so schnell und vielleicht auch
noch nicht so tief, wie sie sich das selbst erwünscht hätten,
wie wir uns das alle erwünscht hätten.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz schon auch mit Fortschritten.
Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass es jetzt wie so an allen anderen Stellen,
wo Russland versucht in irgendeiner Form voranzukommen, sozusagen gar nichts
passiert, sondern die Fortschritte sind sichtbar, sie sind greifbar,
sie sind real und im Hinterland lauern einfach noch sich weiter neue ausbildende,
vorbereitende, aufrüstende Militärgruppen.
Die Ukraine hat nicht im Ansatz das, was sie derzeit in der Hinterhand hat,
an der Front wirklich zum Einsatz gebracht, sondern man macht es gezielt mit
relativ überschaubarem Truppenaufwand.
Sollte jetzt noch vor der Regenzeit und die wird so in den nächsten zwei Wochen
beginnen, glaube ich, in der Größenordnung.
Wetter weiß man nie so genau, aber wir nähern uns jetzt eben dem Herbst und
der Herbst bringt in dieser Region in der Regel viel Regen.
Bevor es richtig kalt wird und dann wieder alles friert,
gibt es einfach diese Matzhiesen und so wie dieser Boden,
der ja ein sehr fruchtbarer Boden ist, aber auch ein sehr matschiger Boden ist,
dort eben aufgestellt ist in der Ukraine, wird einfach das Befahren mit schwerem
Gerät auf unbefestigten Wegen,
Schwierig bis unmöglich. Und das bedeutet, dass sich zwangsläufig Vorstöße wieder
mehr auf Straßen konzentrieren müssen oder eben dadurch auch komplett unmöglich
werden. Das ist schwer zu sagen.
Und dadurch wird sich also auf jeden Fall die Ausrichtung der Angriffe ändern
müssen. Einerseits. Andererseits ist es nun so, dass wir auch wissen,
dass die russischen Truppen sind generell schlecht ausgestattet.
Also an der Front, das sieht man ja immer wieder, wenn Stellung übernommen werden.
Da herrscht eine Disziplinlosigkeit einfach aus einem Mangel heraus.
Mangel an Nahrung, Mangel an Gerät, Mangel an Ausrüstung.
Ja es gibt keine Ordnung.
An guter Führung auch.
Und an guter Führung das noch dazu, aber allein um sich sagen wir mal gegen
die Wettereinflüsse zu wehren ist schon relativ viel zu wünschen übrig.
Und wenn jetzt halt einfach auch noch der starke Regen einsetzt,
dann wird es also noch mal entscheidender.
Sprich die Wehrhaftigkeit dieser Verteidigungsstellung wird durch das schlechte
Wetter und durch die sinkenden Temperaturen noch weiter abnehmen.
Während die ukrainische Seite in der Regel deutlich besser aufgestellt ist,
bessere Führung hat, deutlich bessere Versorgung hat und auch die bessere Technik hat.
Nachtsichtgeräte sind bei den Ukrainern sehr viel verbreiteter als bei den Russen etc.
Und da ja die Strategie sich ohnehin nach den gescheiterten ersten Vorstößen
in den ersten paar Wochen der Offensive von wir fahren jetzt hier irgendwie
mit Panzern über die Grenze und dann gucken wir mal was passiert hinzu.
Wir setzen nur Infanteriegruppen ab und stechen hier und da und dort vor.
Mit Infanterie kannst du natürlich auch bei schlechterem Gelände noch entsprechende
Fortschritte erzielen.
Vor allem wenn sie noch gestützt sind durch Drohnen etc. Und so kann also sein,
dass die Ukraine sehr wohl auch in dieser nassen Herbstphase,
wenn auch mit Einschränkung, ihre Strategie sehr viel besser fortführen kann,
als die Russen ihrer Verteidigungsstrategie fortführen können.
Also die Ukraine hat zumindest angekündigt,
ob sie das auch so durchhalten kann,
ist, dass sie halt einfach weitermachen wird,
so wie auch immer und im Moment,
aktuell ist das Wetter, also ich habe bei mir irgendwie immer Kramatorsk und
Kerson Oblast auch noch auf meinem iPhone so,
wo ich dann gelegentlich drauf gucke, wie denn das Wetter gerade da unten ist
und das ist teilweise besser als hier.
Also im Moment ist da und auch für die nächsten zehn Tage ist jetzt kein großartiger
Regen angesagt und so Tagestemperaturen so von 16 bis 20 Grad.
Also insofern denke ich mal, also die nächsten zwei Wochen ist da noch keine
Änderung zu erwarten und wann und in welchem Umfang es losgeht.
Wir haben ja auch letzten Winter schon gesehen, dass der letzte Winter nicht sehr hart war.
Wir wissen nicht, wie dieser Winter jetzt werden wird, aber nach,
weil so von Klima auf Wetter zu schließen in bestimmten Regionen ist immer schwierig.
Aber wir werden einfach sehen, aber du hast vollkommen recht, dass die Russen, so wie,
dort die Situation teilweise an der Front ist,
nicht überall, aber so in vielen Gebieten Die Versorgungslage ist nicht nur
nicht ideal, sondern wohl teilweise ziemlich desaströs.
Auf der anderen Seite, ja, ist es ganz offensichtlich so,
die russische Armee ist mit einer Übermacht 3 zu 1 an Artillerie beispielsweise
gestartet und hat jetzt ungefähr wohl Parität erreicht,
was die Zahl der Geschosse angeht, die gegenseitig abgefeuert werden.
Das heißt, die Russen kriegen es doch durchaus auch hin, zumindest zahlenmäßig
auch so viel Material an die Front und in den Einsatz zu bringen wie die Ukraine.
Aber was man eben beobachten kann, ist, dass sich das Gewicht so mehr ins Gleichgewicht bewegt hat,
sowohl was die Zahl an gepanzerten Fahrzeugen angeht,
als auch die Zahl von Artilleriesystemen bei Bei Flugzeugen ist die Ukraine noch weit hinten,
bei Panzern ist die Parität unter anderem dadurch hergestellt worden,
dass für den Russen sehr viele Panzer erobert werden konnten,
die westlichen Kampfpanzer, da reden wir jetzt gerade größenordnungsmäßig wahrscheinlich
irgendwo zwischen 100 und 200,
eher 100, die ihren Weg in die Ukraine gefunden haben von ungefähr 1.000,
Kampfpanzern, über die die Ukraine wahrscheinlich aktuell verfügt.
Da sind wahrscheinlich 300-400 davon erobertes russisches Material.
In dem Zusammenhang gab es einen lustigen Clip von der ukrainischen Propaganda,
wo ein Mechaniker bei der Hotline angerufen hat von dem russischen Panzerhersteller,
der so den den T-72 in dieser Modifikation,
oder T-90, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, da muss ein T-90 gewesen sein,
also die den herstellt und der dann halt bei der Hotline angerufen hat und dann Probleme,
mechanische Probleme geschildert hat, die er mit diesem neuen Panzermodell hat
und es ist wirklich zum Schießen,
wie dann der das Gegenüber sagt, ja wir wissen irgendwie von diesem Fehler und
jetzt die Neuen haben das jetzt nicht.
Also wir haben da schon so ein paar Sachen jetzt verbessert und so.
Ja, also lustiges, lustiges Telefonat.
Sowohl, ja, ukrainischer Mechaniker beschwert sich bei der russischen Hotline über die Qualität.
Kriegst du das rausgesucht nochmal, das Video?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
O Mann!
Ja, mit den Links ist es ja immer so eine Sache, die ordentlich zu sammeln.
Sagen zur Quellenlage am Ende übrigens nochmal was, aber lassen Sie uns nochmal
bei der Einschätzung bleiben, wie denn jetzt sozusagen diese Offensive läuft
und wie sie denn vielleicht endet. Magst du da noch ein bisschen was zu sagen?
Naja, man guckt okay, wie ist eigentlich das Ende einer Offensive eigentlich definiert?
Wann endet denn die Offensive?
Und klassisch so in der Literatur, entweder wenn die Truppe das Ziel der Operation erreicht hat,
wo wir sagen können, nein, ist noch nicht erreicht,
eine Vormarschgrenze erreicht wurde,
also wo man dann sagt, okay, hier geht es jetzt nicht mehr weiter,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer, ist es glaube ich auch nicht erreicht bisher,
also Bewegung passiert noch, oder eben wenn sie ihren Höhepunkt erreicht.
Und da ist dann immer eine Frage, wie stark verausgabt sich jetzt die eine Seite.
Und ich würde jetzt annehmen, dass man schon bei der Offensive sich mehr anstrengt,
als man auf Dauer durchhalten kann.
Also dass jetzt eine Offensive einen höheren Einsatz an Material und Soldaten
und höhere Verluste natürlich bedeutet,
als man im Durchschnitt über den gesamten Kriegsverlauf jetzt in der Lage ist
zu absorbieren oder aufzuwenden.
Auf der anderen Seite läuft natürlich Ausbildung und Produktion und Lieferung
hoch, auf beiden Seiten gerade.
Und ja, mein Gefühl ist aber, dass aus verschiedensten Gründen die Ukraine irgendwann
eine operationelle Pause einlegen müssen und dann können wir glaube ich,
dann wird die Offensive auch beendet sein.
Wann das der Fall sein wird, ist noch nicht absehbar, wie gesagt,
vielleicht, wenn der Match da ist, sagen alle, naja, okay, dann haben wir jetzt
einen guten Grund, das nicht zu tun.
Insofern glaube ich, wird die Ukraine irgendwann einfach eine Pause einlegen müssen,
wie auch auch immer man das nennen mag und dann werden sicherlich weitere Offensiven folgen.
Dass den Russen jetzt die Munition ausgeht, hatten wir auch immer wieder das
Thema, das wird glaube ich nicht passieren.
Sie haben Probleme genug davon nach vorne zu bringen.
Was ihnen eher ausgehen könnte, sind dann irgendwann die Artillerie- und Panzerrohre
qualifizierte Soldaten.
Ich glaube, da ist es eher so, das ist eher die, die, die, die kritischen Vorräte, sage ich mal. aber,
Ja, was wir auch in vergangenen Sendungen immer wieder haben,
dass du natürlich als Angreifer eine Übermacht brauchst und die Ukraine hat
keine ausreichende Übermacht,
sie hat in in gewissen Gebieten Vorteile.
Aber es reicht halt nicht aus,
um jetzt einfach schnell die andere Seite zu überrollen,
zumal man, glaube ich, auch nicht bereit ist oder nicht nur nicht bereit ist,
sondern als kleineres Land kann man nicht so viele Verluste absorbieren wie das größere Land.
Als kleinere kriegsführende Partei muss man einfach auch kräfteschonender vorgehen.
Insofern begrenzt das dann auch die Erfolge.
Die Ukraine kann nicht wie jetzt Wagner in Bachmuth 40.000 Sträflinge oder wie
auch immer in den Kampf werfen und opfern.
Wobei ja wahrscheinlich realistisch Wagner zwischen 20.000 und 40.000 Leute verheizt hat.
Und ein Problem, klar, Minenfelder, aber da gibt es eben.
Mittel und Wege und Ukraine ist nicht stark genug, um einfach durchzumarschieren.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, jetzt gesehen aus verschiedensten Gründen und teilweise
ja Unterstützung aus dem Westen zugesagte Dinge sind auch noch nicht da,
also zum Beispiel die raketengestützten Gleitbomben, die,
zugesagt worden waren, das GLSDB, glaube ich, Die letzte Nachricht war,
dass sie im Herbst kommen sollen, wobei die Russen natürlich schon im März ganz
viele davon abgeschossen haben, als im Februar verkündet wurde, dass das kommt.
Aber leider sind die Lieferungen in der Ukraine nur noch nicht eingetroffen.
Keine Ahnung, wo die hergekommen sind, ob die mal ein Badge hatten zum Ausprobieren, aber ich glaube nicht.
Die Russen haben die wahrscheinlich schon im Atlantik abgefahren.
Ja, ja, genau, wir haben die. Und auch andere Dinge und auch das ganze Thema
vom Wegen kämpfen wie die NATO.
Ist natürlich auch nicht so richtig möglich, so mit Combined Arms,
wenn du nicht die entsprechenden Flugzeuge und Raketen hast.
Und da wird sich sicherlich, also in der Luft wird Parität vielleicht erreicht sein,
wenn die Ukraine die ersten 50 F-16 tatsächlich in den Einsatz
bringen kann mit den großen AMRAAMs.
Dann müssen die Russen weiter auf Abstand gehen.
Im Moment ist es so, dass die Ukraine nur Flugzeuge hat für den Luftkampf,
wo das Radar und die Raketen nicht mal die halbe Reichweite haben wie das der
Russen und außerdem das Flugzeug die ganze Zeit auch noch auf den Gegner zufliegen muss,
um das mit Radar auszuleuchten, während Russen Raketen haben und Radarsysteme
in ihren modernen Jets, die einfach die doppelte Reichweite haben.
Und mit der F-16 und den AMRAAMs ist es ungefähr gleichwertig je nach Modell
und und somit sogar leichten Vorteilen bei der F-16 und AMRAAMs.
Im Moment ist es so, dass sich ukrainische Flugzeuge eigentlich nicht auf ein
Luftgefecht mit russischen Flugzeugen einlassen können.
Und wenn, dann geht das schlecht für die Ukraine aus.
Und wenn die F16 da sind, dann werden sich die Russen...
Zurückziehen müssen, ein Stück weit mit ihren Flugzeugen.
Aber schauen wir doch noch mal, was jetzt konkret sozusagen die Ziele waren
und was bisher erreicht wurde.
Gut, bei dem, ich meine, konkret will die Ukraine natürlich die Landverbindung
auf dem Donbass zur Krim so unterbrechen,
um weitere logistische Probleme zu schaffen und eventuell ähnlich wie dann in Kerson,
dann die Russen dazu zu bewegen,
dann von alleine abzuziehen und kampflos das Feld zu räumen,
nachdem man sie dann entsprechend weich geschossen hat.
Aber um diese Landverbindung zu unterbrechen,
also idealerweise, wenn man natürlich bis zum Asowschen Meer durchbrechen und
dann entweder, weiß ich nicht, Melitopol oder Berdyansk oder Mariupol,
idealerweise irgendwann alle, aber zumindest eine von denen zu erreichen.
Aber wenn es aber gelingt, die Front an einigen Stellen bis auf Höhe von Tokmak voranzutreiben,
Dann liegt wiederum ein Teil der Versorgungsroute in Artilleriereichweite und
in direkter Heimatsreichweite.
Und dann wird es halt tatsächlich noch schwieriger,
weil man dann mit billigeren Waffen, also im Moment kann die Ukraine da auch
mit Taurus beispielsweise auch Versorgung unterbrechen,
aber Angriffe auf jetzt bewegliche Ziele und es ist halt sehr teuer,
das heißt man kann dort keine, es lohnt sich nicht einen einzelnen LKW anzugreifen
mit einer Taurus oder so, das bringt es halt nicht und so.
Also deswegen Ziel kann man sagen, irgendwo die Front wenigstens das bis auf
Höhe Togmak und vielleicht sogar Togmak selbst einzukesseln oder einzunehmen.
Das war halt so ein Ziel, was auch diskutiert wurde.
Und davon ist man aber derzeit noch weit entfernt.
Also was jetzt die Ziele der Operation angeht...
Entfernt, im Sinne von 20 Kilometer entfernt.
Ja, aber auch zeitlich, ich sag mal,
wenn man das jetzt mit Zahlen belegen will, dann ist der Durchbruch,
glaube ich, an der tiefsten Stelle jetzt, den man erzielt hat,
in der Größenordnung von zehn Kilometern.
So das heißt, wenn man jetzt sagt, ok 20 müssten es jetzt noch sein, wenn man es jetzt
naiv rein proportional rechnen würde,
kann man sagen, müsste die Offensive noch doppelt so lange dauern,
wenn die so stückchenweise, wenn das stückchenweise weitergeht wie bisher,
dann reden wir nochmal von einem halben Jahr oder einem Jahr irgendwas in der
Gegend, um dann einen Top-Mark einzunehmen.
Sie sind natürlich auch nicht so vermint, wie die ersten zehn Kilometer vermint waren.
Ja, ja, so, aber ja, man kann das eigentlich nicht proportional rechnen,
aber zumindest so, um sich das ungefähr vorzustellen,
Es gibt jetzt auch nicht unbedingt den Grund anzunehmen,
dass das jetzt bald plötzlich schneller sein wird,
sondern es hat sich nicht beschleunigt bisher der ukrainische Vormarsch in den
letzten vier Wochen. Nein, das stimmt.
Aber er ist so konstanter Geschwindigkeit.
Ja, konstanter Geschwindigkeit. Insofern wäre diese Einschätzung so die beste.
Wir können einfach mal festhalten, die Offensive hat das Ziel der Operation
noch nicht erreicht, aber sie ist auch noch nicht zu Ende.
Sie hat auch noch nicht ihren Höhepunkt erreicht, wie wir eingangs gesagt haben.
Nur ist auch nicht absehbar, wann das Ziel erreicht sein wird,
außer eher nicht in den nächsten Wochen.
Das wäre auch meine Einschätzung.
Und wenn dann der Winter kommt, wird es erstmal auch wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt schneller gehen.
Was aber nicht ausschließt, dass es Zusammenbrüche an Teilen der russischen
Front gibt. Das kann immer vorkommen.
Und das haben wir zweimal schon erlebt bisher in diesem Krieg.
Deswegen können wir das nicht ausschließen, dass das auch erneut passiert.
Aber zu sagen, okay, hier an der Stelle wird die Front jetzt bald einbrechen
oder so, das Das kann jetzt gerade derzeit niemand sagen.
Oder behaupten mit hinreichender Sicherheit.
Das ist klar.
Und insofern stehen die Zeichen erst mal weiter auf. Also eine militärische
Entscheidung ist im Moment nicht in Sicht. Aktuell. So kann man,
glaube ich, festhalten.
Naja, schauen wir vielleicht mal so ein bisschen von der Perspektive der Russen
da drauf. Die haben also schon ihre liebe Not diese Situation auch zu halten.
Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass die da jetzt so stehen und sagen so,
ja, Pfff, Ukraine und so, was könnt ihr denn schon? Irgendwie guckt mal hier,
vier Monate gekämpft, zehn Kilometer, ihr könnt ja gar nichts.
Die Russen haben, man kann das so pauschal sagen, haben in diesem Krieg die
Hälfte ihrer Armee verloren.
Bereits, genau.
Bereits, ja. Je nachdem, was man zählt, ist es unterschiedlich.
Aber so eine gute Faustgröße ist, sie haben die Hälfte ihrer Armee verloren,
die sie zu Kriegsbeginn hatten.
Und zwar die bessere Hälfte.
Ja.
Also die bessere Technik, die moderneren Panzer, das modernere Kriegsgerät,
die besser ausgebildeten Soldaten und so weiter.
Tendenziell, ja mehr, ich würde sagen mehr auch gutes Material als schlechtes
Material haben sie verloren und bei den Soldaten schwer zu sagen,
aber sie haben, dass man weiß,
definitiv Elite-Einheiten und gutes Material zu Hauf verloren,
das lässt sich sagen, aber Die Hälfte von der ehemals zweitstärksten Armee der
Welt ist in Deutschland.
Immer noch etwas, was man nicht einfach abhaken kann.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das sind sozusagen die Probleme, die großen Minenfelder,
wobei ich auch schon gehört habe, dass die Russen teilweise auch die Minen schon
irgendwie ausgehen, weil sie einfach versucht haben so viele zu legen.
Also das ist auch alles so, klar, derzeit wirkt das alles so unüberwindlich,
nur das Ganze hat natürlich auch auf russischer Seite so seine Limits.
Also man kann nicht nochmal denselben Aufwand beliebig so treiben,
wie er dort jetzt getrieben wurde.
Man hat sich dort schon auch an die Grenze dessen bewegt, was quasi leistbar
ist, was versorgbar ist, was noch mit Personal bestückbar ist,
was mit Artillerie abgedeckt werden kann, wo ausreichend Minen vorhanden sind.
Das ist halt das eine Ding und auch der kontinuierliche Gegenschlag gegen die
Kommandostrukturen und die Versorgungslinien, das sind halt alles vorbereitende
Maßnahmen, die dann mittelfristig auch noch ihre Wirkung erzielen können.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, diese Linearität, die wir jetzt sozusagen meinen
wahrzunehmen, die muss nicht zwangsläufig so sein, sondern ein Widerstand bleibt
so lange konstant, wie er aufrechterhalten werden kann.
Aber in dem Moment, wo er dann das erste Mal knirscht, dann kann es halt auch
auf einmal sehr schnell gehen. Also die Änderungen sind nicht so ausrechenbar.
Und in dem Moment wo was zusammenbricht kann es sein, dass es dann eben sofort
so ein Kartenhaus ist und sich da gar nichts mehr retten lässt und dann wiederum
größere Geländegewinne zum Beispiel auch stattfinden.
An denen ja sehr viel festgemacht wird, aber ich glaube das ist nicht das einzige
woran man das jetzt eben festmachen kann.
Also dieser Abnutzungskrieg der hat den Russen sehr viel abverlangt in den letzten
vier Monaten und ich glaube er hat den Russen sehr viel mehr abverlangt als
er der Ukraine abverlangt hat.
Also insbesondere natürlich wieder bei der Frage der Reserven gut, also Russland.
Jetzt nicht mehr allzu viele Reserven in der Gegend,
aber sie haben halt, ja, also es ist nicht so,
dass jetzt die gesamte russische Armee dort an der Front kämpft,
sondern auch, ja, weiß nicht,
die Hälfte ungefähr, würde ich
sagen, während in der Ukraine die gesamte Armee sich im Krieg befindet,
während Russland ungefähr, also die befinden sich,
mein Gefühl ist, dass Russland sich immer noch irgendwo zwischen,
ja, es ist eigentlich immer noch eine spezielle Militäroperation und ja,
es Das ist der größte Krieg seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, so irgendwo dazwischen befinden sie sich.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass viele in Russland auch den Krieg nicht wirklich
ernst nehmen oder nicht ernst nehmen wollen,
so auf unterschiedlichsten Ebenen, dass das,
dass das, sagen auch noch mal die russische Antwort, ein wenig behindert,
weil, ja, die Russen sind auch nicht wirklich motiviert, weil sie sich nicht
wirklich angegriffen fühlen.
Weil wir sie auch nicht angegriffen wurden, aber so richtig so oder ja,
also die Russen Auch ja, wir schmeißen nach wie vor...
Verheizen eigentlich ihre Armee stückweise. So hat man das Gefühl und kann sich irgendwann ändern.
Die Umstellung auf Kriegswirtschaft oder das Hochfahren der Rüstungsproduktion
führt teilweise auch zu Erfolgen.
Also, ja, Russland produziert natürlich jetzt mehr als vor dem Krieg an allen möglichen Dingen.
Mit anderen Worten, die Sanktionen haben jetzt nicht dazu geführt,
dass jetzt Russland plötzlich gar nicht mehr in der Lage ist,
Waffen zu produzieren, gerade natürlich bei den einfacheren Waffensystemen, bei den komplexeren.
Ja, wird es halt schwierig. Sie müssen Abstriche machen,
gerade durchaus wegen der Sanktionen und Embargos, schaffen es aber auch ganz
gut, so Embargos zu umgehen, mittlerweile in beiden Richtungen, also sowohl
was ihre Öl- und Gasausfuhr angeht, haben sie es mittlerweile geschafft,
über die Hälfte ihrer Exporte über nicht-westliche Tanker,
die keine westlichen Versicherungen brauchen dem Preis-Cap zu entziehen,
gerade was jetzt Öl angeht und so, und auch was den Import von bestimmten Embargo-Materialien angeht.
Es gibt genug Länder auf der Welt und genug Embargo-Brecher,
die bereit sind, Russland mit Chips und Elektronik zu versorgen.
Ist allerdings das Problem, dass
es halt viel Geld kostet und weil da viel Chinesen dran beteiligt sind,
dort auch, ja sie teilweise über den Tisch gezogen werden,
möglicherweise auch falsche oder defekte Chips angedreht kriegen,
weil sie nicht von offiziellen Distributoren kaufen können, sondern von irgendwelchen shady Händlern.
Das führt dann zu eigenen Problemen.
Aber ja, ein Problem sind die Verluste an bestimmten Waffensystemen,
nach wie vor gesagt gerade Artillerie, wo die Ukraine extrem erfolgreich in
den letzten Monaten Artillerie bekämpft hat und wo,
ich glaube, im letzten Monat alleine 1000 Stück russische Artillerie vernichtet wurden.
Und die Versorgung läuft halt auch suboptimal, weil,
Ja, auch viele LKW zerstört worden sind, Tankfahrzeuge, viele zerstört worden sind.
Also ja, es ist schwierig für die Russen,
aber ja, die kommen halt auch aus einer Situation des Überflusses heraus,
ich meine, man erinnert sich nur, wie sie dann,
ja, mit welchen Mengen, zigtausend Schuss sie sich da teilweise im Donbass an
den an den Front vorgearbeitet haben. Das können sie jetzt nicht mehr.
Also sie haben einen sehr großen Teil ihrer Depots aufgebraucht.
Das was sie aus den Depots jetzt kriegen ist zunehmend in schlechterem in Zustand verrottet.
Sowohl an Munition als auch an Waffen und Waffensystemen müssen sie immer tiefer
in den Schrott reingreifen.
Es kommt aber auch durchaus neues Material. Man kann davon ausgehen,
dass Russland so ungefähr 100 neue Kampfpanzer im Jahr bauen kann und noch mal
mehrere hundert aufarbeiten kann,
dass sie an die Front gehen,
also ich ich sage mal bis zu 300 neuwertige Panzer pro Jahr ersetzen kann und
nochmal 300 bis 600 fahrbereit machen kann,
also dann ohne Modernisierung, sondern aus den Depots holen.
Das heißt, dass sie in der Lage sind, ungefähr 1000 Panzer pro Jahr zu ersetzen.
Das sind so einfach die Größenordnungen gerade.
Also mehr ist es halt nicht.
Und die Qualität im Schnitt geht halt runter.
Tja gut, aber das würde ja immer noch bedeuten, dass sie sich nicht weiter verstärken können.
Bestenfalls können sie in irgendeiner Form den Verschleiß in den Griff kriegen.
Das würde aber nicht ausreichen. Und man sieht ja jetzt auch schon seit...
Seit der Einnahme von Bachmuth ist es, und das ist jetzt fünf Monate her,
das war es dann mit Offensiven. Also über die komplette Front kann Russland
keine einzige Offensive mehr durchhalten.
Sie sind komplett im Verteidigungsmodus und ich weiß nicht, ich bin noch nicht
ganz so optimistisch wie du, was so ihre Möglichkeiten sich da selbst zu erneuern
betrifft. Also mag es bei Panzern noch besser funktionieren.
Also schon für Artillerie-Munition müssen sie jetzt sich schon den Kim Jong-un
da aus Nordkorea per Zug einfahren lassen,
um irgendwie die jetzt mit allem möglichen Kram zu bestechen,
damit die ihre Artillerie-Munition-Bestände an die Russen liefern.
Das ist schon ein Zeichen von Schwäche.
Und ich denke mal, was so komplexere Raketensysteme betrifft,
da werden sie nicht im Ansatz in der Lage sein, ihre Produktion so weit hochzufahren,
wie ihr eigener Verbrauch ist. Von daher ist das alles endlich.
Und ähnlich sieht es ja auch mit ihrer Navy aus etc.
Wobei man trotzdem davon ausgehen kann, dass sie in der Lage sind,
so zwischen 10 und 30 Cruise Missiles pro Monat zu fertigen.
Also bei den verschiedenen Waffensystemen, dann bei S-300, bei Luftabwehrraketen,
die auch Bodenziele bekämpfen können, haben sie auch noch Tausende in der Hinterhand.
Aber ja, auch da wahrscheinlich, was jetzt so Artillerie oder sagen wir mal
Kruzmissiles und Raketensysteme angeht,
sind sie jetzt an einem Punkt angekommen, wo sie mit Ausnahme vielleicht von
S-300 nur noch verschießen können, was sie in der Lage sind, neu zu bauen.
Und das ganze geht ja auch davon aus, dass die Ukraine der einzige Konfliktherd
ist, wo die Russen in irgendeiner Form noch was liefern müssen.
Sie sind ja auch noch präsent zum Beispiel in Syrien, sie sind auch teilweise
präsent über ihre Wagner Ausläufe, die sie jetzt übernehmen wollen,
Afrika, das ist sicherlich nicht so viel Material, sondern mehr Personen.
Also es gibt auch noch diese ganzen Kriegsschauplätze und was man dabei auch
nicht vergessen darf ist, mag ja sein, dass ihre Rüstungsproduktion im besten
Fall, und das ist glaube ich der Fall von dem du jetzt hier sprichst,
Im besten Fall reicht es aus, die Verluste an der ukrainischen Front in irgendeiner Form aufzufangen.
Wofür es aber derzeit überhaupt nicht mehr reicht, ist ihre eigenen Rüstungslieferungen
an andere Länder, ihr eigenes Militärbusiness in irgendeiner Form noch nennenswert am Leben zu erhalten.
Russland ist im Prinzip raus aus dem Spiel.
Niemand bestellt jetzt mehr was, weil erstens hat das Zeug gezeigt wie anfällig
das ist gegen westliche Technik,
zweitens sind sie quasi in ihrer Priorisierung dabei jetzt ihren eigenen Krieg
zu beliefern, das heißt selbst wenn du jetzt Panzer bestellen würdest in Russland
oder Raketen oder irgendwas, Flugzeuge you name it.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass du das einfach nie kriegen wirst.
Zumindest nicht in absehbarer Zeit und schon gar nicht zu irgendeiner Zeit,
wie du eben letzten Endes deinen eigenen Bedarf planst. Und das sind halt Länder
wie Indien und so weiter, die jetzt also wirklich darüber nachdenken,
die auch schon viele Bestellungen abgesagt haben.
Hubschrauber nicht mehr, also Bestellungen von Hubschrauber abgesagt haben.
Andere Technik glaube ich auch, aber Hubschrauber, man weiß das jetzt gerade konkret.
Und das Ding ist, so eine Rüstungsindustrie muss ja auch finanziert werden.
Und die Mittel Russlands sind jetzt nicht beliebig groß und in der Rüstungsindustrie
finanzierst du primär dadurch, dass du eben einen Teil davon einfach anderen verkaufst.
Und das ist halt auch die Basis des russischen Militärsystems.
In dem Moment, wo diese Einnahmen wegfallen, musst du es zwangsläufig aus anderen
Quellen wieder refinanzieren und da ist halt auch der Verkauf von Öl und Gas
und so weiter nicht mehr so einträglich, wie es noch vor ein paar Jahren war.
Wobei zumindest die Zahlen, was ich so gehört habe, wieviel Russland jetzt für
den Krieg ausgibt tatsächlich aus dem offiziellen Budget,
So sind sie glaube ich bei 6% oder so des Bruttoinlandsprodukts.
Da geht noch deutlich mehr. Also Russland könnte,
wenn es wollte, wahrscheinlich zwei- bis dreimal so viel aufwenden finanziell
für den Krieg, wie es das tut. So die Mittel wären da.
Aber das müsste natürlich irgendwo anders eingespart werden.
Und dazu scheint man aber derzeit nicht in der Lage oder Willens zu sein,
in Russland wirklich zu sagen, okay, wir müssen das Ding jetzt gewinnen,
sondern da haben Putin und Scholz vielleicht irgendwie so eine Gemeinsamkeit,
dass sie die Dringlichkeit, diesen Krieg zu gewinnen, offenbar nicht so sehen.
Es wurde darüber gemutmaßt, dass nach den Regionalwahlen in Russland Wenn man
jetzt die Mobilisierung ausrufen würde,
jetzt wird darauf spekuliert, dass nach der Präsidentenwahl Putin seine Wiederwahl
abwarten möchte, obwohl er noch nicht mal angekündigt hat, dass er kandidiert.
Aber das soll wohl in Kürze, wird das wohl erwartet, dass Putin sagt,
dass er nochmal Antritt zu seiner fünften Amtszeit, glaube ich jetzt.
Und dass danach die große Mobilisierung kommt.
Aber offiziell, auch schon gesehen, sie bauen jetzt Denkmäler.
Und so gibt dann neben dem Denkmal für den großen Vaterländischen Krieg,
wo dann die Jahreszahl 1941 bis 1945,
drauf stand, weil für die Russen die ersten zwei Jahre, wo sie noch zusammen
mit Hitler gekämpft haben, wo sie noch mit den Deutschen verbündet waren, zählen sie nicht.
So deswegen hat Deutschland halt 1939 den Krieg, also der Zweite Weltkrieg hat
1939 begonnen und die Russen sind dann in Polen einmarschiert 1939, aber das war für sie
Nicht Teil des Zweiten Weltkriegs, nur für Deutschland war das Teil des Zweiten Weltkriegs.
Russland hat dann der Zweite Weltkrieg erst begonnen, als dann Deutschland in
Russland einmarschiert ist, ja.
Und jetzt haben sie dann auch noch eine neue Denkmäler errichtet,
wo jetzt Ukraine-Krieg so 2014 bis 2023 draufstand.
Also entweder die Russen wissen irgendwie mehr,
dass der Krieg in diesem Jahr noch zu Ende geht, aber auf jeden Fall,
ja, zumindest auf den Denkmälern ist das Ende für 2023 schon eingraviert von den Russen.
Ja, also eine Mobilisierung ist natürlich für Putin schwierig und dass er sie
zu diesem aktuellen Zeitpunkt nicht vornimmt ist natürlich jetzt auch schon
für das ganze Personal an der Front ein Problem,
weil ja, das fehlt halt im Prinzip schon auch an Material und man müsste eigentlich
jetzt schon mobilisieren, wenn man in irgendeiner Form diese Wehrhaftigkeit
aufrechterhalten will.
Geht aber eben nicht, weil passt dann eben nicht zur Wahl.
Gut, man könnte jetzt sagen, die nächste Mobilisierung kommt zu spät.
Das haben wir bei der ersten allerdings auch schon gedacht und vielleicht war
sie auch zu spät für das, was sie eigentlich vorhatten, aber am Ende hat es
immer noch für genug Probleme gesorgt.
So oder so wird es aber schwierig werden, diese zweite Welle der Mobilisierung dann durchzuführen.
Ich meine okay, dann mag er seine Wahl formal gewonnen haben,
aber das ändert ja nichts an der Problematik,
dass das Land dann halt nicht mitgeht und sozusagen so ein Revolutionspotenzial
ja weiter entsteht, weil wir haben ja gesehen, was bei der ersten Mobilisierungswelle
passiert ist, wenn er jetzt wirklich sozusagen auch noch in St.
Petersburg und in Moskau zugreifen möchte, dann flieht also einfach der Rest der Elite auch noch.
Ja, das haben sie gemerkt, die erste Mobilisierung ist nicht gut gelaufen.
Die hat für sehr viel Reibung im Inneren gesorgt.
Und ja, da war man nicht so glücklich mit und hat dann eben auch festgestellt,
ja, dass die Leute auch nicht so richtig Bock haben auf den Krieg in Russland
und das mit diesem ganzen patriotischen Hurra rufen und wir wollen,
wir müssen irgendwie, dass die Ukraine von den Nazis befreien oder unsere ukrainischen
Brüder von den Nazis befreien oder was,
was da halt alles an, an, an, an, an, ja, Geschichten aufgebaut wurde.
Das hat halt die russische Bevölkerung einfach der Führung nicht abgekauft.
Also jedenfalls nicht zu einem Maße, dass sich irgendwie eine größere Kriegsbegeisterung
eingestellt hätte oder die Leute gesagt hätten, jawoll, wir müssen jetzt unbedingt
kämpfen. Also die große Zahl hat einfach keinen Bock auf den Krieg.
Und was sie jetzt dann aber gemacht haben, das sieht man an der Werbestrategie.
Sie haben ihre komplette Werbestrategie für Freiwillige umgestellt und es geht
jetzt in in erster Linie auf Kohle,
so auf wirtschaftliche Sicherheit und Einnahmen, also sie werben jetzt einfach
nur noch damit in Russland, hier geh an die Front und du machst richtig Schotter.
Und das scheint zu funktionieren bei Gerade. Also zumindest...
So die Aussicht auf viel Geld scheint gerade zu funktionieren,
sodass sich durchaus genug Leute, ich meine,
je nachdem in welchen Gegenden die Leute wohnen, können sie,
wenn sie sich freiwillig melden, zwischen dem Drei- und Fünffachen von ihrem
normalen Arbeitsverdienst einnehmen.
Also ich meine es war trotzdem nicht jetzt nicht super viel,
aber so relativ gesehen ist das so, als wenn die Bundeswehr jetzt sagen würde
bei uns okay, also wenn ihr jetzt in den Krieg zieht 15.000,
20.000 im Monat so, 30.000 im Monat ist so das Gehalt, wenn ihr euch freiwillig meldet.
Was glaubst du, wenn die Bundeswehr sagen würde, 30.000,
im Monat, also kündigungssicherer Job erstmal oder zumindest befristet,
wie auch immer, das ist jedenfalls deren Strategie,
dass sie da jetzt gerade Geld drauf werfen und deswegen vielleicht tatsächlich
auf eine Zwangsmobilisierung verzichten können. Problem ist nur...
Erstens, dass wenn die Leute das Geld dann nicht kriegen oder das zu spät kommt,
sie ziemlich unmotiviert sind oder ja, ziemlich pisst sind, wenn das Geld nicht
kommt, wie versprochen.
Und die andere Sache ist, dass am Ende, ja, fürs Geld sie auch dann doch nur
so und so weit bereit sind, Dinge auf sich zu nehmen, ja.
Du bist einfach motivierter, wenn es darum geht,
deine Heimat und dein Haus und deine Freiheit und dein Leben zu verteidigen,
als wenn du dafür bezahlt wirst. Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Aber das Hauptproblem mit Truppen, die finanziell motiviert sind,
ist, dass die sich ganz schnell gegen dich wenden können, wenn du irgendwie
in finanzielle Probleme gerätst, so das heißt.
Ja, also das ist mein Eindruck, dass das gerade passiert, plus natürlich die
normale Wehrpflicht, die ja auch noch gilt, das heißt, da kommt dann auch jedes
Jahr noch ein Jahrgang dazu.
Problem ist nur, dass sie ihren Truppen nicht genügend Zeit geben, sich wieder zu erholen.
Und die Truppen einfach zu lange im Feld lassen und zu hohe Verluste in Kauf nehmen,
das ist halt ein doppeltes Problem, teilweise gibt es Leute,
die seit einem Jahr an der Front sind und nicht nach Hause gekommen sind und nicht weiter,
so dass das demotiviert natürlich die Leute oder das reibt die Leute natürlich
auf, wenn du einfach kein...
Urlaub hast oder keine Regeneration. Die andere Sache ist, wenn dann zu großer
Prozentsatz einer Einheit vernichtet wird, dann geht halt die Kohärenz verloren
und ein wichtiges Know-how verloren und dann wird die auch nicht besonders kampfkräftig.
Also das wäre so im Groben meine Einschätzung, wie sich die Situation gerade
darstellt, was die Rekrutierung und Personal und Motivation angeht.
Ja, auch so Regelungen, die jetzt sagen, ihr bleibt jetzt so lange an der Front,
bis dieser Krieg vorbei ist. Das ist ja jetzt quasi das neue Dekret.
Wenn sich so was dann halt wirklich mal rumspricht, denke ich mal,
wird die Begeisterungsfähigkeit für ein paar Kröten, die man dann am Ende doch
nicht überwiesen bekommt.
Sicherlich bei manchen auch noch ein wenig eine Delle machen.
Das ist natürlich immer die Frage, wer kriegt das mit und wer hat wirklich diese
Wahrnehmung dieser Nachrichten. Aber das ist natürlich auch etwas,
was über die Familien auch wieder zurücksickert.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt eine beliebige Skalierbarkeit hat,
dass du jetzt einfach nur sagen kannst, ihr werdet jetzt alle reich.
Und keiner stirbt so. Das ist halt einfach eine Botschaft, die sich irgendwann
einfach nicht mehr mit der Realität ausreichend verträgt.
Genau, das ist die eine Sache.
Ein anderes Problem, wenn du halt die Leute in erster Linie finanziell motiviert
hast, ist, es gibt auch von der Ukraine eine Menge Geld, wenn man dort mit einem
Panzer oder einem Hubschrauber rüber macht.
Das ist auch sehr lohnenswert so und ja da gab es ja dann auch Fälle,
die jetzt bekannt geworden sind, wo einmal jemand einen Hubschrauber rübergebracht
hat, einen schicken neuen und 500.000,
Dollar dafür von der Ukraine erhalten hat, einen Piloten.
Nur das auch, seine Familie wurde vorher noch koordiniert aus Russland nach
in die Ukraine gebracht.
Das ist wirklich, würde ich sagen, der Topwinner dieser ganzen Situation.
Aber das traut sich nicht jeder.
Also die Situation ist komplex, wie gesagt, im Moment scheint es aber,
scheinen sie mit mit Geld.
Noch genug Leute motivieren zu können und sie können auch nicht so viele ausrüsten.
Das ist halt das andere Bottleneck. Es bringt halt nichts,
wenn sie wie beim letzten Mal dann einen Haufen Leute rekrutieren und es gibt
aber gar nicht genug Ausbilder und keine Uniformen und keine Waffen für die Leute.
Vielleicht hat man daraus auch gelernt und gesagt, okay, das ist der eigentliche Grund,
warum man keine Großmobilisierung macht, weil man keine Großmobilisierung machen
kann, weil zu viele Sachen fehlen, damit das Sinn macht.
Das würde ich auch für schlüssig halten. Die Russen sind jetzt auch nicht völlig
blöd und dumm und doof, nur manche in der Führung.
Aber ja, es werden auch nicht nur falsche oder schlechte Entscheidungen getroffen,
sondern muss immer davon ausgehen, dass der Gegner nicht alles verkehrt macht,
aber die Russen geben sich große Mühe dabei.
Ja, so zum Abschluss gucken wir nochmal auf die allgemeine politische Situation
vielleicht. Wir wollen uns auch gleich nochmal zu den Quellen und euren Fragen noch wenden.
Ja, also wie sieht es sozusagen mit dem Support aus?
Ich denke in Europa ist die allgemeine Unterstützung noch da und nicht sehr
viel schlechter geworden, sondern eher besser geworden in den letzten Monaten
in der Summe, würde ich jetzt mal so daher sagen.
Auch wenn Deutschland wieder mal nicht vorankommt bei bestimmten Themen,
aber wir hatten halt die Situation Dänemark, Niederlande, die also jetzt richtig
aufs Gas drücken, wenn es darum geht, F16 loszuwerden.
USA ist natürlich ein Problem, weil ich weiß nicht, ob ihr so verfolgt,
was in den USA derzeit so abgeht, also das ist wie immer eine echte Shitshow.
Derzeit ist halt so einfach das Haus, also das eigentliche Parlament sozusagen,
ist quasi gerade stillgelegt, weil sie ihren Speaker rausgeschmissen haben,
haben, weil es so eine Revolution gab von diesen acht Super-Loonies aus dem
hart-rechten Spektrum der GOP.
Und jetzt haben sie halt keinen Sprecher, das heißt sie haben sozusagen auch
keinerlei Führung und das bedeutet sie können auch keinerlei Themen schedulen,
also die ganze Planung worüber eigentlich abgestimmt werden soll,
kann derzeit nicht stattfinden.
Nachdem sie ihn rausgeschmissen haben, haben sie als erstes mal eine Woche Pause
eingelegt, um darüber nachzudenken.
So in drei, vier Wochen läuft schon wieder der vorläufige Haushalt der USA aus,
also es ist irgendwie alles ein bisschen unklar. Und diese Die Hard Hardwinger
da, die sind natürlich auch alle irgendwie so russisch infiziert und wollen
halt irgendwie die Unterstützung für die Ukraine streichen.
Gut die USA hat jetzt irgendwie dafür vom Iran beschlagnahmte Waffen,
hat die Ukraine freigegeben, so die sie da irgendwie mal im Golf abgefangen haben mit Schiffen.
Das ist natürlich nur Tropfen auf den heißen Stein und es gibt natürlich noch
die ganzen bisher vereinbarten Lieferungen, aber es ist natürlich auch klar,
dass auch bei der USA die Unterstützung kontinuierlich sein muss, genauso wie bei der EU.
Das muss man also abwarten.
Also es ist sicherlich keine gute oder vorteilhafte Situation.
Inwieweit die jetzt zu Engpässen bei der Belieferung der Ukraine führen kann, wird, ist unklar.
Sicherlich nicht in den nächsten Wochen, aber es ist ja natürlich so,
dass du jetzt die Sachen eintüten muss, die dann in drei, vier,
fünf, sechs, acht Monaten oder so kommen.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt bestimmte Dinge nicht getan oder beschlossen werden können,
werden bestimmte Gelder nicht freigegeben, sodass bestimmte Firmen dann vielleicht
noch nicht mit der Produktion beginnen und dann sich Sachen ja wie gesagt in
einem halben Jahr plötzlich verzögern.
So ist zumindest eine mögliche negative Auswirkung.
Wie weit das jetzt eintreten wird, kann niemand sagen. Aber die Gefahr besteht natürlich. und die USA.
Ist auch dasjenige Land, was jetzt am meisten militärische Ausrüstung geliefert hat, also Waffen.
Europa hat wertmäßig ungefähr dasselbe geliefert, aber mit einem wesentlich
höheren Anteil an Wirtschaftshilfe oder einfach Geld oder andere Hilfsgüter,
während die USA bisher das Gros der Waffenlieferungen bestreiten,
muss man einfach festhalten, weswegen das schon sehr, sehr kritisch ist.
Aber selbst wenn die USA ganz wegfallen würden,
das hatten wir auch vor Monaten mal in der Sendung, glaube ich,
kurz andiskutiert, würde das jetzt nicht dazu führen, dass die Russen jetzt
in der Lage wären, weiter vorzumarschieren.
Es würde also auch ohne US-Hilfe könnte die Ukraine mit Hilfe von Westeuropa,
Europa Plus weiter ihr Land verteidigen.
Also der Krieg würde dadurch nicht zu Ende gehen, wie viele glauben,
wenn die USA sagen irgendwie, Also wenn der Worst-Case passieren würde.
Aber auf der anderen Seite besteht halt im Repräsentantenhaus und im Senat eine
sehr große überparteiliche Mehrheit, die dafür die Ukraine zu unterstützen.
Die Situation aktuell ist nur so, weil das System einfach kacke ist, was die da haben.
Oder zumindest für die Situation, die jetzt eingetreten ist und nicht ausgelegt
ist und nicht gedacht war.
Das mutet an manchen Stellen kurios an. Der Speaker ist halt zum Beispiel der
Einzige, der Dinge auf die Tagesordnung
setzen kann. Der ist sozusagen ein Bottleneck, wenn man so will.
In deutschen Parlamenten ist es so, dass die Tagesordnung von der Mehrheit beschlossen wird.
Das heißt, das Problem mit kein Speaker ist, dass ein Speaker einfach verhindern
kann, dass Dinge auf die Tagesordnung kommen.
Beziehungsweise, wenn es keinen Speaker gibt, kommt auch nichts auf die Tagesordnung.
Also es gibt natürlich einen stellvertretenden Speaker so, aber der hat natürlich
nicht die politische Support und von daher wird es eben alles langsam laufen.
Der darf auch per Statuten nur eine Tagesordnung leiten, die die Wahl eines
neuen Speakers zum Ziel hat.
Achso echt?
Deswegen sind die jetzt gerade erst mal eine Woche in Urlaub gegangen,
das Repräsentantenhaus und wenn die sich wieder treffen,
dann geht es los mit Speaker wählen, dann haben wir wahrscheinlich wieder dieselbe
Nummer, wie wir sie vor halbem, dreiviertel Jahr hatten, als es dann Dutzend
Wahlgänge gab oder so gefühlt.
Und ja, das werden wir halt jetzt wieder sehen. Wirklich leider ein Trauerspiel.
Aber ich glaube, langfristig werden die Amerikaner auch drauf reagieren.
Ich glaube, nach dem, was da jetzt abläuft, irgendwann wird es Gesetze und Regeln
geben, wo sie dafür sorgen, dass so eine Shitshow sich nicht wiederholt.
Aber im Moment ist es halt wie es ist. Und die Lage ist, dass so viel halt nur
so viel ausgegeben werden darf, wie im letzten Jahr auch ausgegeben wurde.
Das ist ja der Punkt.
Aktuell. A. Ich glaube, du hattest noch eine kurze Feststellung zu der Nordkorea-
und Südkorea-Situation. B.
Achso, ja. Da hattest du ja vorhin schon angesprochen, dass Russland gerne mehr
Militärhilfe von Nordkorea hätte.
Und was hier vielleicht vielen nicht so klar ist, ist, dass sich Nord- und Südkorea
immer noch im Kriegszustand befinden. Es gibt keinen Friedensvertrag,
sondern nur einen Waffenstillstand.
Und beide die vermutlich hochgerüsteten Länder der Welt sind.
Nordkorea, wo der Wehrdienst zehn Jahre beträgt, also Wehrpflicht zehn Jahre,
sind um die 20 Prozent der Bevölkerung beim Militär, die Armee 11,
12 Millionen oder so groß,
also mit Reservisten und Südkorea kommt auch auf viele,
viele Millionen und hat eben auch mittlerweile, was Rüstungsproduktion angeht,
sich einen Namen gemacht und ist auf Platz 4 oder 5 mittlerweile der Rüstungshersteller.
Vom Ranking Rüstungsexporteure der Welt geworden. Und beide Länder haben gewaltige Munitionsvorräte.
Also niemand weiß genau wie viel, aber es könnte in die zig Millionen Artilleriegranaten gehen.
Und ein interessanter Gedanke war jetzt, sollte Nordkorea seine Unterstützung
für Russland ausweiten und dafür im Gegenzug Dinge bekommen,
wie zum Beispiel bestimmte Raketentechnologie oder bestimmte moderne Waffen,
die Nordkorea fehlen, oder Atomtechnik oder was auch immer,
wird Südkorea, das bisher keine Waffen anliefert,
die im Ukraine-Krieg eingesetzt werden, sondern da läuft das so,
dass die an NATO-Länder oder Drittländer liefern, die sich die südkoreanische
Munition auf Halde legen und ihre Halden dann an die Ukraine liefern.
Aber wenn jetzt Nord- und Südkorea
tiefer involviert werden und dieses Eskalationspotenzial ist zumindest da,
dann hätten wir quasi so etwas wie einen Stellvertreter-Weltkrieg dann zwischen
Nord- und Südkorea, der in der Ukraine ausgefochten wird.
Und das fand ich eine.
Interessante und allerdings auch beängstigende Feststellung,
dass das auch passieren könnte.
Ja, genau. So viel zum Stellvertreter-Weltkrieg zwischen Nord- und Südkorea in der Ukraine.
So, jetzt haben wir noch ein paar Fragen bekommen.
Wir haben euch nach Fragen gefragt und da wollen wir nochmal kurz drauf eingehen, kurz.
Ich glaube die erste können wir nicht beantworten.
Wer hat Nord Stream gesprengt? Wir hatten uns ja hier zu Nord Stream einst sehr
analytisch drauf eingelassen,
was denn da nun wirklich passiert ist und haben ja auch unsere eigenen Thesen
oder Vermutungen zumindest aufgestellt, wie so die Motivationen einer ihrer Player sein könnten.
Jetzt gab es ja auch verschiedene Berichte.
Wie schätzt du das ein?
Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich habe keine
wirklich überzeugenden neuen Informationen oder Einblicke und habe deswegen
nichts Zweckdienliches gerade zum Thema zu sagen, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, da brauchen wir noch ein paar Jahre.
Vielleicht wissen wir nach dem Krieg Bescheid irgendwann eines Tages.
Aber im Moment ist da zu viel Desinformation im Raum und zu wenig Fakten,
als dass man da zu einer guten Bewertung gelangen könnte.
Ich, es gibt viele Verdächtige, die alle ein Motiv hatten oder denen man zumindest
ein Motiv unterstellen könnte. Russland gehört dazu, definitiv.
Oder es steht für mich nach wie vor weit vorne.
Aber so am Ende des Tages, ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht. Peter fragt, ihr habt erwähnt, dass die Ukraine
nach dem Krieg vermutlich die am besten ausgerüstete Armee Europas sein wird.
Stimmt das auch noch, wenn das unter dem US-amerikanischen Land at least zur
Verfügung gestellte Gerät zurückgegeben wurde, beziehungsweise was ist mit dem
restlichen Gerät? Kann es sein, dass die Ukraine hier etwas verkaufen wird oder
muss, um andere Teile zu bezahlen?
Ja, also vor längerer Zeit habe ich auch noch eine Debatte über das Thema,
okay, was heißt denn eigentlich jetzt Land and Lease und was kommt denn dann
zurück am Ende des Tages?
Und ja, ich halte das ganze Land and Lease eigentlich eher für einen politischen Euphemismus,
der es den Geberländern irgendwie leichter machen soll,
Militärgeräte zu verschenken, weil da kommt nicht viel zurück.
Ich meine, Munition leihen ist ja schon mal irgendwie, okay,
das kann man glaube ich schon mal alles abhaken. Das heißt, alles was irgendwie
explodiert, so wird wahrscheinlich auch explodieren und nicht zurückgegeben werden.
Und der Rest, also ein Großteil des Materials wird einfach zu verschlissen sein
oder zerstört werden, dass es sich überhaupt lohnen würde, das Ganze irgendwie zurückzuliefern.
Also sprich, die Geber haben sich ja in der Regel von dem Material getrennt
oder sich anguckt, was an Material geliefert wird, jetzt an Panzern und so, weil...
Sie, ja, mit wenigen Ausnahmen wird da nicht, wurde eh nicht das beste Gerät geliefert.
Und ich kann mir das höchstens in Einzelfällen vorstellen,
dass ich so zum Beispiel im Zweiten Weltkrieg, wenn dann irgendwelche Schiffe oder so,
irgendwelches Militärgerät, was in einer Anzahl vorhanden ist,
was nicht mehr benötigt wird, ist oder zu aufwendig oder zu teuer zu betreiben.
Aber ich glaube eher, dass wenn, dann wird das Zeugs verschrottet werden.
Und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass die Ukraine also jetzt in größerem
Umfang hier Dinge verkaufen wird.
Höchstens dann, ja, nee, ich glaube, Bis auf weiteres wird man auch alles,
was man hat, sich lieber selber auf Halde legen für den Fall,
dass die Russen wiederkommen.
Ich sehe da nicht, dass selbst nach Kriegsende werden wir leider.
Einen weiteren Aufbau von Rüstung sehen in der Ukraine und man wird sich erstmal
von nichts trennen, was irgendwie noch brauchbar ist. Das ist meine Einschätzung.
Ich denke auch, dass diese Rückzahlung, die im Prinzip im Raum steht,
die wird dann eher auf einer anderen Ebene geführt werden.
Also ich sehe eine irgendwann erfolgreiche und wieder aufgebaute Ukraine mit
einem starken Rüstungssektor ausgestattet und mit einem gut ausgewählten Militär
wird den USA und auch der EU sicherlich in vielen anderen Bereichen sehr hilfreich sein können,
abgesehen davon, dass so ein Payback nicht unbedingt nur über,
diese militärische Ebene und Ausrüstung geführt werden kann,
sondern genauso eben über das, was die Ukraine ansonsten noch in Massen hat. Getreide und Ehe.
Sonnenblumenöl und einfach sozusagen mit den Stärken und den Ressourcen,
die dieses Land hat einfach an anderer Stelle uns viele gefallen wird tun können
und da wird man sich sicherlich schon irgendwie einig werden.
Ich glaube von den Gebern erwartet niemand, dass irgendwas zurückkommt von dem
was in den Kriegsgebiet geliefert wird. Das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Noch eine Frage. Notorisch interessiert fragt, kann Russland wirklich keine
besseren Vergeltungsschläge durchführen? Ein leeres Hotel nach Krim,
Marinequartier etc. Was können Russlands Geheimdienste gut und was nicht?
Ja das ist eine gute Frage und das ist gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten denke ich,
aber ich habe schon so den Eindruck, dass sich auf der einen Seite ihre Strategie
auch leicht ändert gerade,
es gab jetzt auch das erste mal mal so wirklich strategische Angriffe mit ihren Loitering Munitions,
also mit ihren frei fliegenden Lancet Drohnen, die sozusagen normalerweise an
der Frontlinie auf Panzer und anderes Gerät runter gehen.
Damit wurden dann eben auch mal Militärflughäfen in Saarbrückia angegriffen,
also geparkte Mig Flugzeuge, ich weiß nicht ob sie zerstört wurden,
aber zumindest beschädigt wurden.
Das hat man vorher so nicht gesehen. Was man halt gesehen hat sind eben Angriffe
auf leere Hotels, also im Prinzip Terror.
Und das ist halt so auch ein wenig, glaube ich, die Doktrinen gewesen Russlands
und das mag auch mit einem Mangel an aufklärerischen...
Techniken und Möglichkeiten einhergehen. Das ist halt einfach Russland teilweise
gar nicht besser weiß, dass sie nicht wissen wo.
Andererseits haben sie aber schon zu Beginn des Krieges Rüstungsunternehmen
angegriffen, sie haben Truppenkonzentrationen ja sogar direkt an der polnischen Grenze angegriffen.
In Lviv gab es Raketenangriffe auf Rekrutierungszentren, wo die ganzen internationalen
Soldaten ankamen und so weiter.
Alles so ein bisschen Stückwerk und nichts wirklich strategisches und Beobachter
fragen sich das eigentlich auch schon länger,
was Russland eigentlich mit diesem ganzen Quatsch erzielen will,
weil sie eigentlich ihre ganzen Möglichkeiten so überhaupt nicht für Military
Gains nutzen, sondern stattdessen halt einfach nur random irgendwelche Wohngebäude zerstören.
Das mag zwar für ihr eigenes Gefühl ganz hilfreich sein, aber es ist einfach
für den Verlauf des Krieges weitgehend irrelevant.
Allerdings sind die Russen besser geworden beim Targeting, insbesondere ein bisschen schneller.
Das Problem, warum sie so schlecht getroffen haben, ist, dass sich die Ukraine
angewöhnt hat, viele Stellen oft umzuziehen.
Also regelmäßig umzuziehen. Und dass die Rossen einfach zu lange gebraucht haben,
immer um ein Ziel aufzuklären und dann tatsächlich den Angriff durchzuführen,
war dann oft niemand mehr da oder gerade niemand
da, weil man nämlich keine aktuellen Informationen hatte oder wenn man aktuelle
Informationen hatte, das zu lange gedauert hat, um die Operation dann oder den
Angriff durchzuführen.
Sind sie jetzt ein bisschen besser geworden?
Insbesondere was Drohnen angeht. Sie feststellen, dass sie auch an vielen Stellen
die Art und Weise angefangen haben zu kopieren, wie die Ukraine kämpft mit Drohnen.
Wobei Russland beklagt, dass sie eine Drohnenunterlegenheit haben,
jetzt so bei kleinen Drohnen, dass die Ukraine in der Lage ist,
ungefähr 5000 Drohnen pro Woche, glaube ich, zu verheizen und ungefähr auch
gleichzeitig in der Luft hat.
Also so wahrscheinlich zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt kann man davon ausgehen,
sind wahrscheinlich 5.000,
ukrainische Drohnen irgendwo unterwegs und die Russen kommen da auf deutlich kleinere Zahlen,
was jetzt so die Front angeht und ein weiteres Ding ist,
dass wir halt ja auch kein hundertprozentig klares oder eigentlich ein sehr
schlechtes Bild davon haben,
wie groß denn ukrainische Verluste sind beim ukrainischen Militär.
Vielleicht gibt es auch durchaus bessere Vergeltungsschläge und es werden auch
militärische Ziele erfolgreich angegriffen,
aber wir erfahren nichts davon. So.
Denen kann allerdings in größerem Umfang auch nicht wirklich der Fall sein,
weil natürlich gut, wenn man guckt,
womit sich die russische Seite dann immer brüstet, bei ihnen sind es natürlich
immer in der russischen Propaganda alle Angriffe sind chirurgische Schläge auf
ausschließlich militärische Ziele und das sind offiziell alles keine Vergeltungsschläge,
Sondern wenn dann irgendwo Zivilisten getroffen werden,
war das dann entweder die ukrainische Luftabwehr oder sie haben eine Rakete
abgeschossen, die es dann versehentlich, irgendwo hat dann ziviles Ziel getroffen,
sagen die aus russischer Perspektive.
Aber denke generell, wenn Russland wirklich jetzt generelle oder Führungspersonal
in größerem Umfang eliminieren würde auf ukrainischer Seite,
dann würden wir mehr davon hören, vor allem aus russischer Seite.
Das heißt, da wir von den Russen so etwas nicht hören,
kann man davon ausgehen, dass sie tatsächlich nicht in der Lage sind,
so gute Vergeltungsschläge oder Enthauptungsschläge zu führen oder hochwertige Ziele anzugreifen,
mobile Hochwertziele anzugreifen, ein Kraftwerk oder so oder ein Bahnhof.
Ja, der ist halt wo er ist.
König weglaufen. Vor allem, man muss auch sehen, im Verlauf dieses Krieges sind
einfach unzählige Generäle der russischen Armee umgekommen.
Und die Normalität für solche Kriege ist, Generäle sterben nicht im Krieg.
Also vielleicht ein Herzinfarkt oder so, aber nicht dadurch,
dass sie irgendwie einfach an der Front aufgerieben werden, ne?
Ja, das kommt eher selten vor. Und was jetzt bei Materialverlusten angeht,
hält sich die ukrainische Seite natürlich auch bedeckt, selbst wenn Material zerstört wurde.
Aber wir wissen auch, dass sie viel mit Decoys arbeiten, also mit aufblasbaren
Heimats und Panzerattrappen und so.
Sodass man selbst da es sein kann, dass die Russen glauben, irgendwas zerstört
zu haben, was dann aber unter Umständen Attrappen sein können.
Und insofern, ja, nichts genaues weiß man nicht,
aber tatsächlich der Eindruck, dass die Ukrainer gezielter zuschlagen können
und gezielter Hochwertziele ausschalten können, also,
Luftabwehrstellungen, Planungskommandoeinrichtungen und Munitionsdepots und
so. Da scheinen die Ukrainer einfach deutlich besser zu wissen,
wo was ist und auch eine längere Liste von Zielen zu haben, als sie überhaupt
abarbeiten können mit dem, was dass sie an Waffen zur Verfügung haben.
So, nächste Frage. Ford Prefect. Hat die ewige Diskussion um Taurus und Attackams
den Russen genügend Zeit gegeben, in signifikantem Umfang Hochwertziele außer
Reichweite zu bringen oder zu schützen?
Ich würde sagen so eher nein und auch wenn ich es nicht weiß,
ob sie tatsächlich irgendwo diese Hochwertziele vielleicht doch aus der Reichweite gebracht haben,
aber ich kann sagen, warum ich nicht glaube, dass das stattfindet,
weil diese Hochwertziele sind ja nicht durch Zufall oder zum reinen Vergnügen an der Front.
Also der General ist jetzt nicht an der Krim in seinem Hauptquartier gewesen,
weil das da so geil ist oder weil er da Urlaub machen wollte oder so,
sondern es gibt halt eine gewisse Notwendigkeit, aus verschiedensten Gründen
auch für hochrangiges russisches Personal, sich relativ in Frontnähe aufzuhalten.
Und auch, ja, du brauchst auch Depots in Frontnähe.
Also du musst, ja, es gibt da halt auch beim Material so eine hierarchische Verteilung.
Das kommt mit Zügen an, in größeren Mengen. Also du kannst das nicht mit einzelnen
LKW oder PKW von Moskau an die Front fahren.
Du hast halt verschiedene Transportketten und Mittel und du kommst nun mal nicht
drum hin, Dinge irgendwo zu konzentrieren.
Und das Einzige nur scheint zu sein, dass offenbar in Russland es einfacher
zu sein scheint, auch Kollaborateure zu finden und Leute zu bestechen.
Also es gibt Hinweise darauf, dass auch ein Großteil der Informationen direkt
von russischen Militärs kommen.
Auskommen, also gerade dieser Anschlag da auf das Hauptquartier,
dass das quasi Offiziere diese Information an die Ukraine verkauft haben,
weil sie sich schlecht oder unterbezahlt fühlten und keinen Sinn in ihrem Dienst dort.
Der Eindruck besteht, dass die russische Armee nicht nur ein internes Korruptionsproblem
hat, sondern korrupt ist halt korrupt und,
Naja, und offensichtlich schreckt man dann auch nicht davor zurück,
dann an den Feind Informationen zu verkaufen, wenn denn die Bezahlung gut genug ist.
Hochwertsziele muss ja jetzt nicht unbedingt Personal heißen,
sondern eigentlich haben wir diese Frage schon beantwortet.
Ja, ich meine U-Boote, große Schiffe sind jetzt durch Long-Range-Raketen Storm
Shadow ausgeschaltet worden.
Die Russen wissen, dass sie mittlerweile in der Bedrohung dieser Raketen sind,
aber setzen halt auf ihre Flugabwehr und das funktioniert eben dann nur in Teilen,
unter anderem, weil es entweder mal nicht funktioniert oder eben durch so eine
Überlastungsstrategie der Ukraine und andere Möglichkeiten, die sie da vielleicht
noch haben in irgendeiner Form diese Systeme zu umgehen.
Und daher kann man sagen, die Diskussion schadet jetzt nicht,
aber was halt wirklich schadet ist, dass es halt einfach alles so lange dauert,
weil sagen wir mal, wir hätten jetzt diese Taurus-Raketen im Bestand der Ukraine,
dann könnten halt noch ganz andere Ziele erreicht werden, dann könnte man halt
wahrscheinlich, dann hätte man vielleicht auch schon die ganze Marine.
In Sevastopol ausknocken können, weil dafür sind diese Raketen gedacht.
Also die Taurus-Raketen sind ja gerade deshalb so beliebt.
Nicht, weil sie so eine hohe Sprengkraft haben, das auch, sondern weil sie halt
auf der einen Seite einen Pfad fliegen können, der aber die ganze Zeit variiert.
Also die haben natürlich keinen ballistischen Wege,
aber die können im Prinzip dermaßen viel zigzag fliegen, dass sie überhaupt
nicht ausrechenbar sind und sie sind dabei noch nicht mal von GPS oder so etwas abhängig,
weil sie halt mit so einer Elevation Map fliegen, das heißt sie trennen quasi
die Oberfläche und sind vollkommen unabhängig von Satelliten und damit sind
sie natürlich deutlich resistenter gegen Electronic Warfare.
Man kann ja diese Raketen quasi verwirren und ihnen verbieten,
GPS-Signale ordentlich zu empfangen.
Also im Prinzip sind die Taurus halt sehr ähnlich dem Storm Shadow Sculpt,
ist eigentlich die deutsche Variante davon.
Ich habe jetzt noch keinen genauen Vergleich gesehen. Ja, ich meine Taurus gibt
es nicht als Exportvariante mit kurzer Reichweite, sondern die sind alle 500
Kilometer, soweit ich weiß.
Aber Storm Shadow ist eigentlich auch 500 Kilometer, nur die Exportvariante,
die eigentlich nicht Storm Shadow heißt, kann nur die 250.
Kilometer, Naja, wegen Kurzstrecken-Raketen-Beschränkungsvertrag,
ich weiß nicht, welche das sind.
Ja, auf jeden Fall gibt es da, ich glaube, für Raketen über 300 Kilometer gab
es da so ein Vertragswerk, das versuchte, deren Proliferationen einzuschränken.
Aber das hatten wir in früheren Sendungen auch schon mal.
Das ist das Thema. Und ja, also die Waffen kommen halt, wann sie kommen.
Und wir hatten die Diskussion ja am Anfang, dass man sich vielleicht im Westen
auch noch was offen halten will, um irgendwie nachlegen zu können.
Weil irgendwann, ja, also spätestens wenn dann die F-35-Kampfflugzeuge kommen,
dann ja, es kann man nur noch Mengen steigern und nicht mehr nicht mehr Technik.
Aber interessant in dem Zusammenhang noch ist mit den F-16,
weil von wegen älteres Gerät und in welcher Variante und so liefert man,
die scheint sich mittlerweile im Westen auch die Sicht durchzusetzen,
zumindest bei den Holländern, die dann gesagt haben, nee, also das macht keinen Sinn,
den Ukrainern irgendwie immer Waffen zu liefern,
die einfach nicht auf dem neuesten Stand sind und dann zu erwarten,
dass die neue tolle Westtechnik dann irgendwas bewegt, wenn aber 30 oder 40
Jahre altes Zeug geliefert wird.
Sondern wenn, dann muss man den Ukrainern einfach auch Material liefern,
was mindestens gleichwertig ist, was zu dem Material, was die Russen haben,
also zu dem guten Material oder besten Material, was die Russen haben, idealerweise besser.
Und ja, also zu der Frage, die werden, also die Russen werden erst sich in Sicherheit
bringen oder umstrukturieren in dem Moment, wo es tatsächlich Verluste gibt.
In entsprechendem Umfang und nicht vorher.
War ja bei HIMARS ganz genau so.
Ja.
Okay, letzte Frage und die leitet jetzt sagen wir mal noch auf einen anderen Blog über.
Justin gefragt, mein Eindruck ist, dass die Quellen auf Twitter immer unzuverlässiger
und schlechter werden, aber auf Mastodon finde ich nicht wirklich gut Ersatz.
Wie sieht denn bei euch aktuell die Quellenlage aus?
Naja, also Twitter oder Twix, wie ich das jetzt nenne, Ist in der Tat ein schlechter
Begleiter geworden, weil man es einfach so scheiße lesen kann,
seitdem man jetzt irgendwie gezwungen ist diese offiziellen Clients zu benutzen.
Im Web kann man das eh nicht benutzen und überhaupt müssen wir ja die Twitter
Diskussion gar nicht kurz aufmachen. Also ich habe einfach Schwierigkeiten das
zu machen. Inwiefern die Quellen da jetzt schlechter geworden sind oder besser
kann ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht beurteilen.
Aber was wir halt sagen können und was wir jetzt hier auch nochmal ausrollen
wollen, ist, woher wir eigentlich so unser ganzes Halbwissen beziehen.
Lass mich, bevor wir da reingehen, auch noch zwei, drei Sätze zu Twitter sagen.
Ja, es ist schade drum. Es war mal ein wirklich geiles Medium und ich hoffe,
dass nach dem Zusammenbruch, der irgendwann kommen wird, sich vielleicht irgendwas,
entweder was anderes etabliert oder es irgendwie gerettet werden kann.
Aber im Moment ist die Situation auch einfach,
dass ich, ja, ich twittere jetzt kaum noch und bin auch selten da,
ich einfach nicht bereit bin,
dort meinen Content jetzt mask zur Verfügung zu stellen unter den Bedingungen
und ich auch einfach damit demonstrieren möchte,
indem ich quasi in so eine Art Twitter-Streik trete oder mein Engagement reduziere,
wie ich denn auf diese Umbenennung und die ganzen anderen Pläne eigentlich reagiere, so deswegen ja.
Im Dies Elon.
Genau, genau.
Genau, genau. Pavel ist im Twitter-Streik.
Also ich meine, ich habe mich auch jetzt nicht groß angekündigt,
aber es hat sich aber auch ergeben,
dass ich einfach kein gutes Gefühl hatte irgendwie auf Twitter aktuell zu posten,
solange der, ja, solange der Musk da so einen Unsinn treibt.
Und die ganzen Änderungen, die erfolgt sind, fand ich alle durch die Bank weg.
Da kann ich da nichts Positives dran finden.
Ich sehe da keinen Plus. Und das Problem ist so, ja, auf Twitter,
ich meine, Quellen war schon immer irgendwie unzuverlässig.
Und man muss immer gucken, ohnehin, wem man folgt.
Und das Medium ist da so ein bisschen zweitrangig, würde ich sagen.
Ob das jetzt Instagram, Facebook, Twitter, ja, irgendein Blog ist oder so.
Am Ende, denke ich, ist es die Person, die das dort veröffentlicht oder die
Organisation, die das dort veröffentlicht und gegebenenfalls kommentiert.
Und ja, und man muss sich ohnehin in einem breiten Spektrum,
glaube ich, informieren, um zu einem Bild zu gelangen, was vielleicht nicht völlig danebenliegt.
Und das wäre jetzt meine Überleitung auf, wie wir denn zu unseren Einschätzungen aktuell gerade kommen.
Also ich muss zugeben, die Größe, also es gibt, also anders.
Twitter ist immer noch irgendwie so eine Quelle, allein dadurch,
weil eben viele, die so diese bröckchenhafte Berichterstattung machen mit mehr
oder weniger guten Einschätzungen, nach wie vor mehrheitlich das noch auf Twitter tun.
Ich hab da eine Ukrainerliste, da schaue ich immer wieder rein,
aber es ist halt auch sehr schwierig geworden, diesem Content zu folgen,
weil einfach die Software so scheiße ist.
Deswegen tue ich es halt auch kaum noch. Und von daher hat sich auch so unsere
Quelle mehr in Richtung YouTube verschoben,
wo halt einfach eine ganze Menge gute Beobachter und Kommentargeber unterwegs
sind, was ich sagen muss, da kriegt man dann schon noch ein ganz gutes Bild.
Wir haben jetzt mal auch eine Liste zusammengestellt.
Das findet ihr alles in den Shownotes von Kanälen auf YouTube.
Also es ist jetzt wirklich alles auf YouTube. Nicht, dass nicht manche von denen
auch noch auf anderen Kanälen zu finden sind. Sind sie teilweise.
Also auch auf Twitter, auch auf Mastodon teilweise und so weiter.
Aber primäre Outlets sind hier eigentlich immer die Videokanäle.
Und wir haben auch ein paar schon mal erwähnt, sicherlich nebenbei,
wollten aber jetzt mal hier kurz die Liste durchgehen.
Ich würde sagen, wir klappern das mal ab und sagen zu allem mal kurz was.
Ja, und es sind halt auch Ausgangspunkte.
Oft findet man dann dort Links oder Referenzen oder Hinweise,
denen man dann folgen kann, wo man dann noch weiter in die Tiefe gehen kann.
Aber, ja, was ich dann teilweise auch tue, also ich schaue mir dann schon auch
nochmal die Originalvideos an und...
Oder Originalquellen oder recherchiere auch Sachen, wenn mir irgendwas komisch vorkommt.
Und ich recherchiere das dann halt auch deshalb, weil mir das wiederum Informationen
darüber gibt, wie sorgfältig denn dieser YouTuber oder jetzt jetzt tatsächlich gerade arbeitet.
Und gut, vielleicht noch dazu gesagt, ich gucke mir auch ein gewisses Spektrum
gerne an, Wobei definitiv eher sich so das Spektrum von auf Ukraine-Freunde
bis Wissenschaftler verändern würde.
Vor allem fokussiert und gucke mir natürlich auch russische Propaganda und und so weiter an,
aber tatsächlich eher weniger, weil halt was von russischer Seite kommt,
sich einfach extrem häufig als Unsinn entpuppt oder als falsch entpuppt und
insofern ist es halt sehr mühselig und frustrierend,
sich jetzt aus russischen Quellen oder pro-russischen Quellen zu jetzt mal informieren,
weil leider der Informations- oder Wahrheitsgehalt nicht sehr hoch ist.
So das ist das Problem, was ich damit habe.
Aber ich versuche mich trotzdem immer wieder regelmäßig dazu zu zwingen,
auch andere Positionen mal anzuschauen und zu gucken.
Ja, um nicht zu sehr einem Bias oder Einflüssen von Zensur, die im Krieg auch stattfindet.
Und weil ich gerne hätte,
dass die Ukraine gewinnt und weil ich mich freue über ukrainische Erfolge und
weil russische Erfolge schmerzhaft sind und deprimierend,
man sich dann lieber nur die Kanäle anguckt, die halt ukrainische Erfolge vermelden,
weil alles andere wäre zu schmerzhaft.
Also diesen Reflex versuche ich halt zu widerstehen, so gut es geht.
Aber ja, und eben, weil ich dann festgestellt habe, dass das doch schon eine
ganze Menge Leute sind, denen ich da regelmäßig folge oder denen wir regelmäßig folgen.
Und ich bin nach wie vor im Schnitt jeden Tag so, ich sag mal,
eine Stunde, würde ich sagen, damit beschäftigt, ukraine informationen zu rezipieren.
Ja läuft bei mir ähnlich. Zu den Quellen muss man auch noch sagen,
also das Medium was wahrscheinlich wirklich die absolut meiste Zahl an Primärquellen
hat, ist mit Sicherheit Telegram.
Also das ist wirklich der Ort, wo alles abgeht. Aber da spielt es sich dann
halt auch meist auf ukrainisch und auf russisch natürlich ab.
Gibt sicherlich auch ein paar englische,
gibt auch ein paar gute deutsche Kommentatoren, die das dort machen.
Ich empfinde allerdings das konsumieren von Nachrichten auf Chatkanälen als,
sagen wir mal, etwas schwierig, also dass es, sagen wir mal,
wenn man es jetzt noch wilder treiben möchte, als wir das hier ohnehin schon
tun, dafür, dass wir auch noch andere Dinge im Kopf haben.
Dann könnte man das da nochmal steigern, aber von daher sind wir eher auf der
zweiten oder dritten Rezeptionsebene angesiedelt würde ich sagen,
also wo Leute die, sagen wir mal, näher dran sind oder die,
sagen wir mal, die Sprache, eine der beiden, im Idealfall beide Sprachen gut können,
Ja die, also das sozusagen aufnehmen und dann eben umwandeln so und wir sind
ja im Prinzip dann auch wieder nur so eine nachgeschaltete Interpretationsebene,
weil wir versuchen eben Long Range hier über einen Zeitraum von drei Wochen,
vier Wochen, manchmal auch zwei Monaten, die Gesamtheit der Informationen zu
wiederzugeben und dabei eben unwichtige Details rauszulassen,
wichtige Details vielleicht auch mal voranzustellen, um einfach jetzt euch,
die in unseren Augen Interessierte sind,
die sich kümmern, die auch gerne dranbleiben möchten, aber aus irgendwelchen
anderen Gründen, aus emotionalen oder zeitlichen Gründen, nicht so die Gelegenheit
haben, dem ganzen Kram so täglich zu folgen, wie wir das tun.
Im Übrigen, ja, vielleicht noch eine Anmerkung, irgendwie Joscha Bach,
irgendwie hat jetzt in einem Podcast seine Motivation erwähnt,
warum er eigentlich überhaupt schreibt oder tweetet oder Sachen öffentlich macht und die Motivation,
seine Motivation, und mir geht es da einfach ähnlich,
ist, Bei Twitter habe ich es oft gesagt,
dass ich das tue, um meine Gedanken zu strukturieren und sagen,
ich sehe jetzt auch diesen Podcast einfach als Teil,
mit dir zusammen jetzt höher daran teilnehmen zu lassen,
wie wir das Rezipierte verarbeiten und dann zu einer Einschätzung gelangen,
sowohl was das große Bild angeht, aber dann eben auch, weil wir ja normal Nerds
sind, an manchen Stellen tief in die Details runterzugehen.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Reihe, auch wenn wir gleich sehen,
von den Leuten, denen wir da folgen, sind auch Profis, die das Ganze professionell machen.
Militär sind, Ex-Militärs oder entsprechende Militäranalysten,
die machen einen recht großen Teil von unseren Informationsquellen aus.
Das heißt, die reichern das dann schon mal mit Informationen an.
Und irgendwann weiß man dann halt auch Bescheid. Wenn man diesem Konflikt jetzt
zwei Jahre lang fast täglich folgt,
so gelangt man auch zu einer gewissen Einschätzung,
die, glaube ich, Wert hat, weil nicht jeder hat die Zeit, sich jeden Tag eine
Stunde oder zwei hinzusetzen und diese Nachrichten zu rezipieren.
Da muss ich einmal im Monat jetzt zwei, drei Stunden hinsetzen.
Uns hören, dann kriegt man, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Überblick mit ein paar ganz netten Anekdoten.
Aber okay, das – Nur wenn wir dann auch mal auf den Punkt kommen,
Pavel, und dann auch mal die Quellen jetzt hier mal ausbreiten,
um vielleicht auch die Sendung langsam mal zum Ende zu führen,
dauert ja schon lang genug.
Also, hier in nur teilweise sortierter Reihenfolge ein paar Kanäle,
die uns als recht hilfreich erscheinen.
Ja, wobei das kein umfängliches Endorsement von all dem ist,
was dort gesagt wird auf den Kanälen, sondern ja,
man immer auch kritisch sein sollte,
auch bei Leuten, egal wie sympathisch sie sein mögen und egal,
wie sehr man das glauben möchte, was sie sagen, sollte man doch versuchen,
ja, seinen Verstand walten zu lassen.
Selbstverständlich. Das erklärt sich ja von selbst. So, los geht's mit Reporting from Ukraine.
Das ist so ein Daily Update.
Nicht immer über alles, sondern meistens ein Blick auf ein Schwerpunktgeschehen
aus den letzten Tagen. Manchmal tagesaktuell, manchmal erst zwei, drei Tage später.
Wenn dann berichtet wird, immer sehr ausführlich, vor allem auch mit so Military
Maps. Das ist also so eine Quelle, wo man dann tatsächlich den kompletten Verlauf
der Frontkämpfe nachvollziehen kann, aber eben mit ausgewählten Schwerpunkten.
Definitiv so einer dieser Kanäle, die immer die gute Seite präsentieren und
selten mal die Verluste der Ukraine in den Vordergrund stellt,
aber trotz alledem ein sehr informativer Kanal, weil man auch sehr viel über
Taktiken lernen kann, die an der Front zum Einsatz kommen.
Zu Reporting von Ukraine sagen, ja, da würde ich eine gewisse Vorsicht walten lassen.
Geht da sehr in die Details, oft rein und so, aber ja, trotzdem eine nützliche Quelle.
Aber würde ich sagen, ja, schon sehr, wie du richtig sagtest,
Ukraine-fokussiert oder pro-ukrainisch, also stark pro-ukrainisch.
Ja, ja, aber auch...
Ich hab, ich schaue mir das immer
sehr genau an, weil ich das wirklich gut aufgearbeitet finde und selten,
also mir fällt jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nichts ein, es mag mal gegeben haben,
dass irgendetwas komplett falsch, also dass sich irgendwas herausgestellt hat,
dass es komplett falsch dargestellt worden ist.
Also es ist schon eine gute Darstellung der Dinge, es werden natürlich Sachen,
Aber auch eine sehr selektive, ja durchaus selektive.
Selektiv aber super interessant in seiner Selektion. Ähnlich wie Enforcer,
der Enforcer, ich weiß nicht genau, weißt du wo der herkommt?
Das scheint mir ein Amerikaner zu sein.
Naja, das ist ein Amerikaner, relativ jung auch, in den frühen Zwanzigern und
so, ist da irgendwie auch rein gerutscht, hat sich extrem da reingesteigert
mit täglichen mehrstündigen Streams auch.
Und so ist nicht so kompakt,
was er macht, sondern vor allem seine Streams,
die sind auch so ungefähr drei Stunden, ja,
und das ist sozusagen fast jeden Tag oder jede zwei,
ich glaube, er ist jetzt auf einen ein bis zwei Tagesrhythmus im Schnitt umgestiegen und das ist so,
ja, dann auch sehr Also mit viel Hurra auch oft,
weil er versucht eben auch Geld zu sammeln, hat recht erfolgreich glaube ich
mittlerweile ein paar hunderttausend Dollar geschafft mit seinem Kanal für die Ukraine einzusammeln.
Und ja, persönlich, wie gesagt, es ist ein bisschen sehr Hurra für meinen Geschmack,
aber trotzdem sehr aktuell und ja.
Und vor allem mit etwas flüssigerem Englisch. Also es ist einfach,
manche anderen Kanäle sind manchmal teilweise etwas schwer zu folgen.
Das ist hier definitiv nicht der Fall.
Dann relativ wichtige Personen würde ich sagen, Jake Broe, ein Amerikaner,
der auch so einen militären Hintergrund hat und der...
Ehemaliger, ja, also er hat halt bei der Air Force in einem Raketenbunker gesessen
und war halt für Atomwaffen so zuständig ein paar Jahre,
also sozusagen in einem Atombunker gesessen und
das muss ich sagen, ist so einer der sympathischsten, so einfach seine Art,
die Dinge zu präsentieren, finde ich sehr angenehm.
Ist oft einen Tag hinterher mit den aktuellsten Dingen.
Also da sind andere Quellen oft einen Tag früher dran.
Aber die Art und Weise, wie er das aufbereitet und auch seine Meinung und seinen
Kontext und seinen Sachverstand dazu gibt, und das auf eine sehr sympathische Art.
Also wenn ich mich jetzt auf einen beschränken müsste,
So würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen,
Jake Bro liefert fast täglich einen ganz guten Überblick in 15 bis 20 Minuten
über das Geschehen mit zusätzlichem Kommentar.
Das stimmt. Ich würde noch einen zweiten Kanal dazu empfehlen,
der für mich eine gute Ergänzung wäre, aber es stimmt schon,
er ist sehr umfangreich.
Das heißt, er macht immer so 20, 25 Minuten alle zwei Tage ungefähr und dann
kommen aber viele Dinge hintereinander zur Sprache und er verliert da auch nicht
sehr viel mehr Worte drüber, als es vielleicht erforderlich ist.
Kontextualisiert manches, das ist schon wirklich gut und das gilt auch für viele
dieser Kanäle, ich würde sogar sagen für fast alle.
Alle beteiligen sich halt auch in irgendeiner Form immer am Spenden sammeln,
am vermitteln von Geldern für einzelne Truppengruppen etc. Das ist so ein ständiges
Meme in diesen ganzen Kanälen.
Da passt dann auch wunderbar Ryan Macbeth rein,
der eigentlich einen C++ Programmier YouTube Kanal starten wollte,
aber dann zu Beginn des Krieges sozusagen in die Ukraine gezogen wurde und dann
mit sehr interessanten Videos zu einzelnen Fragestellungen auf einmal sehr große
Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt hat.
Das war das erste Video, mit dem er so ein riesiges Echo gehabt hat,
das ging um russische...
Waffen irgendwas, ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, Panzer,
warum die Panzer irgendwie einen Cook-Off haben oder irgendwie sowas,
also irgendein Detail glaube ich, das ging dann total auf die Decke und mittlerweile
ist er auch ein regelmäßiger Begleiter geworden des Krieges.
Ist jetzt nicht ganz so News orientiert sondern er schnappt sich immer wieder
so einzelne Themen raus, Fragestellungen die an ihn herangetragen werden,
macht auch so Shortclips und so weiter,
auch ganz lustig aber interessant sind eigentlich immer so solche Sachen mit ja,
keine Ahnung hier neue Waffentechnik was ist da jetzt wirklich dran oder spezifische
Fragen wie umgegangen wird und mit sehr viel Erfahrung aus dem Militärbereich
so, also er war selber glaube ich im Irak im Einsatz und so.
Er war,
Unteroffizier und hat sehr viel Erfahrung einerseits von Führung und Dynamik
in der Armee, aber auch, merkt man so, von durchaus Taktik, Strategie,
aber auch technischen Details und ist auch ein kritischer Denker.
Und ja, nimmt auch eine ganz interessante Position ein,
also er ist auch aktuell hat er auch einen Job,
sagen wir mal so ein bisschen als Analyst, beziehungsweise auch ein bisschen
einen nachrichtendienstlichen Hintergrund im Sinne von,
aber ja, also ist jetzt kein Nachrichtendienstler oder so, aber beherrscht eben
durchaus auch professionelle Methoden.
Also er geht sehr methodisch vor und auch wenn er bestimmte Fragen antwortet,
ist das jetzt Desinformation, ist das jetzt wahr oder nicht und so macht er
da eine ganz gute professionelle systematische Aufbereitung und argumentiert
sehr gut seine Meinung, finde ich. Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Hat viele Einblicke auch in das amerikanische Militär und macht auch immer wieder
so Sondersendungen zu wie funktioniert denn das jetzt konkret im amerikanischen
Militär. Nimmt das dann auch als Beispiel dafür wie Dinge in Russland nicht
funktionieren oder in der Ukraine anders funktionieren etc.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr interessante Quelle, weil er einfach Gesichtspunkte
liefert an oft so Themen, wo man überhaupt gar nicht erst drüber nachgedacht hätte.
Logistik, Fragen und so weiter. Also alles mögliche. Also da erfährt man doch sehr viel.
Ähnlich und diesmal unsere erste deutsche Quelle ist Thorsten Heinrich,
der ist auch extrem umtriebig, hat sowohl einen deutschen als auch einen englischen
Kanal, wo er teilweise dieselben Informationen liefert, also macht sozusagen
alles auch zweimal einmal auf deutsch einmal auf englisch, hat auch so ewig lange Streams.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher was sein Hintergrund ist, er bezeichnet sich als ihr
Lieblingssalonstratege,
ist halt eigentlich Militärhistoriker, war mal,
wie er schreibt, Verteidigungs- und Außenpolitiker, hat ein paar kleinere Publikationen gemacht,
das ist so ein bisschen seine Selbstbeschreibung und ja,
der hat auch so einen Newskanal, also auch hier gibt es, weiß nicht welche Häufigkeit,
ein zwei Tage, so ein bisschen wie Jake Brow ähnlich, noch ein bisschen mehr
Fokus auf das Militärische, weil das ist ja nun mal sein, sein Kerngebiet.
Und auch das finde ich immer eine ganz gute Ergänzung, nochmal so ein anderer
Blickwinkel auf das Frontgeschehen.
Ja, also kann ich auch nur bestätigen so und wie ich vorhin schon sagte,
Er guckt sich halt auch viel auf russischer Seite um und ja,
bewertet und kommentiert dann die russischen Gerüchte oder auch die russische
Seite und sagt aber auch immer ganz, ganz gut.
Also gibt eine Einschätzung auch jeweils von den Quellen, wo er sagt,
ja, keine Ahnung, nur Gerücht.
Geht halt allgemein eben auch so vor, okay, wenn die ukrainische Seite etwas berichtet,
was für sie ungünstig ist, oder die russische Seite etwas berichtet,
was für sie ungünstig ist, ist das natürlich tendenziell glaubwürdig,
oder glaubwürdiger als umgekehrt, wo man dann zweifeln muss.
Und er hat dann auch die im Blick, genauso wie wir das machen,
dass wir dann sehen, okay, wer hat denn dann...
Mit seiner Einschätzung eigentlich in der Vergangenheit richtig gelegen oder
relativ wenig Fehler gemacht oder qualifiziert die Dinge einfach vernünftig,
nicht so, so war es, sondern das ist die Nachricht und das sind die Umstände
und ja, ich glaube sie oder ich habe große Zweifel daran oder wie auch immer.
Und ja, sein Englisch ist ein bisschen holprig, aber okay, kann man sich anhören,
auch auf Englisch, finde ich.
Ja, der nächste Kanal, den ich sehr angenehm finde, ist Ukraine Matters.
Georgie nennt er sich, gibt nicht zu viele Informationen über sich,
oder zumindest habe ich noch nicht alle zur Kenntnis genommen.
Sei selbst kein Ukrainer, lebt in Dänemark, macht regelmäßige Sendungen auch
alle paar Tage, ist mit einer Ukrainerin verheiratet.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo er selber herkommt, er ist definitiv kein Däner,
also irgendwas aus Osteuropa, würde ich sagen.
Er sagt er ist selber nicht Ukrainer, nehme ich das mal so zur Kenntnis,
mit einer Ukrainerin verheiratet, er spricht, er versteht Ukrainisch und Russisch
und folgt von daher den ganzen Quellen und sagt halt auch selber,
i watch military experts so you don't have to und er hat dort viele Freunde
und Familie und so weiter und he cares.
Anyway, also er ist auf jeden Fall voll dabei und ist auch ein guter Translator
würde ich sagen des militärischen Geschehens.
Es geht nicht so sehr um die militärischen Strategien, sondern er gibt vor allem
immer so gutes big picture up darüber wie die aktuelle Situation zu interpretieren ist.
Wo sind Fortschritte, wo sind Rückschritte, was ist schwierig,
warum ist es schwierig, warum ist es kein Problem, dass irgendwas schwierig ist etc.
Außerdem ist er auch ein guter Organizer und hat also auch eine sehr sehr aktive Discordkanal,
wo irgendwie viel Hilfe zusammenläuft, also ist wirklich so einer derjenigen,
die sich einfach massiv für die Ukraine einsetzen und seine YouTube Öffentlichkeit
an der Stelle einfach so nutzt, um Geld dazu kommen zu lassen.
Aber eben auch sehr viel Interpretation des Nachrichtengestehens.
Finde ihn sehr sympathisch und schau das sehr gerne an.
Macht auch längere Livestreams und hat immer so Sendungen von so 10 bis 15,
20 Minuten mal mit so Map Updates, also wo es halt wirklich konkret um den Frontverlauf
geht oder eben andere Aspekte berücksichtigt werden.
Finde ich auf jeden Fall ganz toll und ist eine gute Ergänzung zu,
wenn du sagst, eigentlich brauche ich nur Jake Bro, würde ich sagen,
den noch dazu, den Georgie, da hat man echt eine gute Mischung.
Ja jetzt wird's ein bisschen spezieller, Sucho Minus finde ich lustig,
hat irgendwie einen strangen Akzent, wo ich noch nicht so ganz rausbekommen
habe, wo der jetzt eigentlich herkommt, ist mir irgendwie unklar,
ich glaub der wohnt irgendwo in Asien und Philippinen oder irgendwie sowas,
ich hab's glaub ich zwischendurch mal rausgehört, aber dann schon wieder vergessen.
Vielleicht ist er Australier, ich habe keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall kommt er
mit ukrainischen Städtenamen nicht sonderlich gut klar.
Aber er schnappt sich halt auch immer so diese ganzen Zerstörungsvideos auf
Telegram raus und kommentiert die dann nochmal teilweise sehr ausführlich und
recherchiert auch teilweise nach.
So zum Beispiel bei der Zerstörung der Schiffe jetzt und der Reluzierung der Schiffe,
wo also hat er sehr schön in so einem 10 Minuten Video nachgewiesen,
wie aktuelle Satellite Images interpretiert werden müssen, um rauszufinden,
okay, welche dieser Landesschiffe existieren jetzt eigentlich noch.
Also er ist Australier und ja, covert sozusagen diesen militärischen Industriekomplex
so und die australische Militärinvestitionsstrategie und kümmert sich halt sehr
um das Geschehen in Russland und der Ukraine.
Und wir haben da glaube ich schon so einige Videos von ihm hier auch immer wieder
als Diskussionsgrundlage genommen.
Also eigentlich ist er Gamer und seine
Videos sind im Wesentlichen PowerPoint-Präsentationen, die er kommentiert.
So kann man sagen und dann eine Stunde lang immer ein bestimmtes Thema oder
eine Situation auseinander nimmt. So was, dass sich so Fragen wie,
geht den Russen jetzt die Munition aus oder was weiß
Ja, was ist den Ukrainern? Wie hoch sind die Verluste? Solche Fragen.
Und dann eben ja mit einem großen Schwerpunkt auf Logistik.
Und ist eigentlich, glaube ich, Gamer aus dem Bereich Militärsimulation,
glaube ich, oder Game-Entwickler auch.
Und ist darüber in die Situation reingerutscht und hat eher mehr so einen wirtschaftlichen Hintergrund.
Auf jeden Fall kann er mit Präsentationen sehr gut umgehen,
also eine sehr gute Präsentation, er redet schnell, also ich habe auch die Erfahrung
gemacht, dass ich manche Themen dann doch lieber mal so auf 0,75 Geschwindigkeit
anhöre, weil da steckt viel drin, also da ist relativ wenig Luft dazwischen.
Nicht, dass er hektisch spricht, dass er einfach die Informationsdichte ist
so groß, dass ich manchmal mehr Zeit brauche, darüber nachzudenken,
was jetzt gerade gesagt wurde, aber es geht da einfach zack,
zack, zack, zack, zack. Also in einer Stunde bringt er mehr Informationen unter
als andere in drei Stunden, das ist wirklich irre.
Sehr, sehr, sehr aufschlussreiche Videos zur NATO,
zum russischen Militär, auch zu anderen Aspekten,
die Türkei und der Krieg, Naval Warfare, was geht ab im Schwarzen Meer,
Munitionstypen, also wirklich alles mögliche, ganz hervorragende Quelle.
Perun. Ja dann ein besonderer Freund von uns glaube ich und von vielen,
weil sein Kommentar immer sehr erhellend ist, ist Anders Puck Nielsen.
Konflikt and War ist selber ein militärischer Analyst aus Dänemark,
der auch immer wieder auf eine sehr angenehme, sympathische Art und Weise das
Geschehen kommentiert.
Ich sehe gerade vor sechs Stunden eine Sendung rausgebracht,
die ich noch nicht gesehen habe.
How is the war going? Das sind immer so seine interessanten Updates zu was er
so denkt. Also so ein bisschen so ähnlich wie wir das hier machen nur sehr viel kürzer.
Kann man von daher auch empfehlen, wenn ihr sozusagen nicht so viel Zeit verschwenden
wollt hier auf den Krieg,
dann seid ihr bei ihm ganz gut aufgehoben alle paar Monate mal ein Update zu
bekommen, naja aber sehr angenehmer Typ der wohl auch sehr viel die dänische
Öffentlichkeit im Fernsehen über den Krieg bedient.
So der dritte unserer Spezies ist Vlad Vekslar. Der ist selber Russe,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, also er ist in Russland geboren, aber in England aufgewachsen.
Ja und ist halt ja Wissenschaftler, also einer der intellektuellsten,
also ihn würde ich als intellektuellen bezeichnen.
Absolut, absolut.
Und ja, er analysiert halt die,
Russland und Putin und die politische Situation in Russland auf einer sehr,
ja, also philosophisch, im Prinzip Politik-philosophisch und viele komplexe
Zusammenhänge und ist teilweise schon ein harter Tobak,
also die die Art und Weise, wie er redet, muss man schon, also es ist nichts
zum so eben nebenbei hören, sondern verlangt einem eine gewisse Konzentration.
Ab, glaube ich, ihm zu folgen, weil er auch eine sehr abstrakte Art hat,
aber auch eine sehr interessante Art.
Und ihm viele Einblicke, ich sage, Analysen liefert, was Russland und Putin
angeht, weil er das 20 Jahre lang wissenschaftlich auch verfolgt hat.
Also wirklich ein sehr interessanter Typ. In seiner Selbstbeschreibung schreibt
er dann übrigens auch noch seine Inhalte beruhen auf seinen Erfahrungen mit
einer schwächenden neurologischen Erkrankung.
Er sei vor 20 Jahren als Forschungsstudent in Oxford erkrankt und konnte jahrelang nicht gehen,
nicht sprechen und lesen und kümmert sich davor täglich um diese Krankheit und
meint sie gibt ihm eine einzigartige Perspektive auf die Behinderung,
das tragische Element im Leben. Aber auch das Schöne.
Also der ist wirklich sehr angenehm zu hören, finde ich ganz toll und solltet
ihr zumindest mal reinhören. Ein oder anderen Aspekt.
Gerade wenn es darum geht zu verstehen wie die russische Seele so tickt.
Das ist glaube ich die Hauptqualität dieses Kanals.
Wenn man sich immer denkt, was geht mit euch, warum ist das so,
warum gibt es keinen Widerstand, wie funktioniert diese Gesellschaft,
da hat er wirklich sehr interessante Einblicke geliefert und macht das nach wie vor.
Die nächsten beiden verfolge ich nicht so sehr, da musst du mal sagen, Artur Rehi.
Ja, Artur Rehi nennt sich auch Estonian Soldier, ist auch, muss ich sagen, ein,
Aktivist, der sehr viel praktisch für die Ukraine tut, also der regelmäßig auch
rüberfährt und dann gespendete Fahrzeuge und Ausrüstung übergibt an verschiedene
ukrainische Einheiten.
Das dokumentiert er allerdings nicht so sehr auf YouTube, sondern auf anderen Kanälen.
Dann allerdings macht er auch regelmäßig, also eigentlich fast täglich auch
einen Ukraine-Überblick Und ja,
hat und seine Spezialität ist so ein bisschen dann die,
die Namen seiner Patreon-Abonnenten am Ende vorzulesen mit einer ästhländischen
Aussprache und sie so komplett zu verstümmeln, so das ist das Ding.
Ansonsten, ja er hat eher so ein bisschen so eine humorvoll-emotionale Art und
ist wie gesagt auch ein sehr pro-ukrainischer Kanal.
Aber er erzählt jetzt auch nicht allzu viel Unsinn.
Der nächste dann noch William Spaniel, das ist ein Professor,
unter anderem auch Spieltheoretiker, der auch ein Buch über den Ukrainekrieg
geschrieben hat, über die Ursache und so, das er in jedem seiner Videos hauptsächlich bewirbt.
Aber er ist so der Experte, also eine Spezialität von ihm ist das Thema Linien auf Karten.
Und so was er oft tut, ist quasi die Erwartungshaltung auf beide Seiten,
wie denn der zukünftige Frontverlauf sein wird, so zu skizzieren und zwar eher
also abstrakt so und wann der Krieg ist zu Ende.
Ich sag mal, wenn beide Seiten sich auf den Eindruck haben,
dass der zukünftige Frontverlauf gleich sein wird,
aber in der Regel läuft der Krieg so lange weiter, weil die Erwartung des einen,
wo der Frontverlauf in Zukunft sein wird, und die Erwartung des anderen,
wo der Frontverlauf in Zukunft sein wird, halt weit auseinander klaffen.
Und das macht er ganz gut.
Damit veranschaulicht er ganz gut Dinge. Und wie gesagt, ja,
sein Schwerpunkt ist halt Spieletheorie und es kommt auch aus der akademischen Ecke.
Und ja, mit Schwerpunktkrieg. Also sein, just a professor who studies war and
game theory ist seine Selbstbezeichnung.
So jetzt noch mal ein ganz anderer Kanal, den ich auch sehr interessant finde.
Heißt 4020, 1420, ich weiß nicht genau warum. Da wird auch nicht viel erzählt.
Wer die Leute sind. Das ist so ein jugendlicher Russe, der mit Mikrofon und
Kamera durch russische Städte läuft und die Leute zum Krieg in der Ukraine befragt.
Also nicht nur, aber vor allem.
Und das finde ich wirklich interessant. Also das ist,
also ich weiß gar nicht wie er damit wegkommt so, andererseits er fragt ja nur,
ja also behauptet nicht viel,
manchmal so ein bisschen tangentschick aber ja er fragt so,
Wir behaupten ja immer es gibt eine Russophobie,
wie denkt ihr darüber oder wie seht ihr den Krieg in der Ukraine und was wäre
für euch irgendwann ein Gewinn oder wie fühlt ihr euch jetzt,
wo Bachmut genommen wurde, fühlt ihr euch jetzt besser und so weiter,
also wirklich interessante Fragen.
Habt ihr Angst vor einem ukrainischen Einmarsch in Russland oder so war auch,
fand ich auch sehr interessant.
Genau und es ist sehr interessant zu sehen, einerseits weil es natürlich viele Leute gibt,
die halt auch dann wirklich so komplett propagandakonform antworten,
aber auch viele Jugendliche,
die nicht so viel Angst haben und durchaus mal ihre Meinung sagen und sagen so,
so wie es läuft, bin ich überhaupt nicht mit einverstanden und man merkt also
auch wirklich so, wie die Generationen sich da unterscheiden,
aber dass du letztlich auch in allen Generationen kritische und genauso unkritische Leute findest.
Es liefert so ein bisschen ein Verständnis für das Selbstverständnis der Russen.
Nicht, dass es irgendwas besser macht, aber es ist halt ein interessanter Blick
auf die Bevölkerung, ohne jetzt die ganze Zeit nur die Großkopfhatten abzuklappern.
Ja, dann haben wir noch zwei. Anna from Ukraine.
Ja, das ist so eben auch, ja, ich folge ihr nicht regelmäßig,
muss ich dazu sagen, aber so,
sie beleuchtet halt dann auch nochmal andere, völlig andere Aspekte,
was jetzt die Ukraine angeht und ja, es ist eine interessante Perspektive.
Manchmal hat man auch ein Ding mit Jake Bro zusammen gemacht und so.
Also ja, gut.
Also es ist vielleicht interessanter,
wenn man jetzt weniger das Hardcore-Militärische, sondern dann andere Aspekte,
auch der, was die Ukraine betrifft in dem Kontext, also die Ukraine ein bisschen
kennenlernen möchte, so würde ich das mal ausdrücken.
Also auf kultureller Ebene und so, aber auch oft mit Bezug zum Krieg auch.
Aber ja, dann hast du halt auch so Dinge dazwischen,
wie sie dann über traditionelle ukrainische Stickerei berichtet oder auch viel
zum Thema jetzt Propaganda sagt oder auch so Erste-Hand-Berichte aus der Ukraine.
Ja, also kann man auch folgen, ist auch regelmäßig, also macht auch fast täglich Dinge.
Ja, Vlad Veksla hat es ja auch im Interview gehabt und andere.
Dann last but not least haben wir noch den Caspian Report, den kennst du auch besser.
Ja, das ist so eine Ergänzung, das ist eigentlich weniger jetzt Ukraine-Krieg,
sondern also auch zum Thema,
aber liefert so eine interessante politische Außensicht auf Westeuropa aus der Sicht eben ja,
eher von Leuten mehr aus dem Osten, also sozusagen Gegend ums Kaspische Meer herum.
Das ist so die Perspektive und hat manchmal sehr interessante Einschätzungen,
zu denen man als Europäer nicht so kommen würde oder Berichte auch über Aspekte
oder Länder oder Konflikte im Zusammenhang jetzt auch mit Russland,
die man gar nicht so auf den Schirm hat.
Oder auch der Kommentar innereuropäischer Konflikte, also das Verhältnis jetzt Türkei zu EU und so,
oder was zwischen Iran und Afghanistan los ist,
oder über Polen, oder ja,
was würde passieren, wenn die Ukraine tatsächlich NATO-Mitglied wird und solche
Dinge, aber auf eine sehr interessante Art und Weise und mit auch frischem.
Gedanken und Aspekten und ja.
Ich finde solche Kanäle immer ganz hilfreich, weil sie einem so ein bisschen
die Perspektive noch erweitern.
Weil es ist ja einfach so, also die Perspektive, ich meine mal ganz ehrlich,
wir sind nicht in der Lage die Welt aus der Blickrichtung von,
was weiß ich, Kasachstan zu beleuchten oder so.
Da wissen wir schon über Kasachstan nicht genug, geschweige denn könnten wir
zuverlässig auf dem Globus anzeigen wo es ist.
Und das finde ich immer sehr spannend, weil Konfliktherde und außenpolitische
Beziehungen gibt es halt potenziell zwischen jedem Land und jedem anderen Land
auf dieser Welt und bei irgendwie 160 Ländern ergibt sich daraus einfach ein
super komplexes Gebilde und das wird man auch nie vollständig verstehen können, das tut niemand.
Aber einfach immer nur so diese rein europäisch oder noch schlimmer deutsche
Perspektive zu haben oder vielleicht die amerikanische,
weil einem die permanent um die Ohren geschmiert wird, so das reicht halt nicht,
um irgendwie Dinge zu verstehen und ich hab auch gelernt, dass einfach die Welt
dann im Zweifelsfall immer nochmal 30 mal komplizierter ist,
als man das so ursprünglich gedacht hat, gerade deswegen und deswegen finde
ich solche Kanäle immer sehr interessant.
Es gibt noch ein paar weitere, aber das würde uns jetzt von so einer ukrainebezogenen
Liste von Quellen doch weit weg bringen. Mal gucken, vielleicht später mal.
Das ist so das, was wir jetzt euch mal empfehlen können. Und je nachdem,
was euch am meisten reizt, könnt ihr ja mal gucken, ob das was für euch ist.
Ein ein habe ich noch so nämlich den
russischen media monitor so ein
eher spezieller kanal der halt so untertitelte auszüge aus dem russischen fernsehen
im wesentlichen bringt wo man sich dann angucken kann was so russische propagandisten
wie hauptsächlich soll.
Solowjow oder Margarita Simonian, was die da so verzapfen oder was im russischen
Fernsehen über Elon Musk erzählt wird.
Also es ist schon bisweilen wirklich absurd, was man dort zu sehen kriegt.
Relativ kleine Auswahl, allerdings eine recht spezielle Auswahl.
Ich habe auch mal versucht, zu gucken, was kriege ich denn an russischem Fernsehen
eigentlich übers Internet noch zugegriffen.
Geht grundsätzlich auch, aber Großteil des russischen Fernsehens ist halt normales
Fernsehen und da ist von Krieg nicht viel zu spüren.
Also einen Eindruck, den ich mir aus erster Hand auch nochmal verschaffen wollte.
Also der Krieg ist im russischen Fernsehen kein großes Thema.
Das kann ich jedenfalls aus erster Hand sagen, sondern ja.
Fashion Media Monitor ist ein Projekt von Julia Davis, die ist selbst in der
Ukraine geboren worden, also ist in Amerika, also eine Amerikanerin, aber geboren in Kiew.
Und naja spricht halt die Sprache und beobachtet das eben alles für uns und
das ist teilweise wirklich ein Haarsträumen, was sich da in diesen Kanälen dort
abspielt, also auf RT und etc.
Auf diesen ganzen Hetzer Kanälen und ja diese ganze Absurdität,
das bringt der Russian Media Monitor wunderbar herüber auf jeden Fall.
Ansonsten noch eine Erwähnung ganz kurz,
also sowohl auf dem Kanal der Bundeswehr als auch des österreichischen Bundesheeres
kommen so alle paar Monate mal auch durchaus interessante Darstellungen der
Situation und wenn da mal was ist,
kann man glaube ich auch empfehlen da mal reinzuschauen, aber das ist halt,
ja, alle paar Monate. Also die berichten, glaube ich, noch seltener als wir.
So, Pawel, jetzt machen wir Schluss hier, damit wir die Vierstunden nicht noch voll kriegen.
Okay, das war jetzt unerwartet lang, das Ganze. Ja, ich kenne das schon mit dir.
Ja, naja, jetzt ist wieder meine Schuld. Nein, nein, das ist unsere gemeinsame Schuld.
Wir bereiten das ja gerne auf und vielleicht muss es jetzt auch wieder nochmal
ein paar Wochen halten. Also könnt ihr euch das ja auch häppchenweise geben.
Und manche Leute benutzen den Podcast, habe ich gehört, auch gerne zum Einschlafen.
Von daher ist das dann auch ganz gut, wenn er nicht zu früh zu Ende geht,
je nachdem wie viel Einschlafprobleme man vielleicht hat.
Alright, dann machen wir jetzt keinen großen Hackmack mehr hier zum Schluss,
sagen vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank für eure Fragen,
für eure Kommentare, dann später hoffentlich auch im Blog.
Vielen Dank auch für eure finanzielle Unterstützung der Meta-Ebene und ja,
ich würde sagen, das war's dann erstmal von uns.
Wir melden uns zu gegebener Zeit wieder, wenn irgendwas wichtiges passiert ist
oder wenn wir das Gefühl haben,
dass genug passiert ist, dass es mal wieder der Zusammenfassung und Einordnung
bedarf und von daher hoffen wir, dass ihr uns auch weiter begleitet.
Vielleicht kurzer Hinweis, wir haben jetzt auch so ein UKW Mastodon Account, ukw-podcast.social,
wer da unterwegs ist, kann uns da auch sozusagen direkt anschreiben.
Ja, das war es dann aber auch.
Ich würde sagen, Tschüss und bis bald.
Jo, mach's gut.